This button is not working. What floor are you guys going to? I'm going to three. Oh, maybe I'll just press that button and we can just go there. I'm not really going to a floor. I'm just here for the ride. You're just riding the elevator, just trying to meet people. My name's Jason. And this is my friend Sean. What's your name, friend? My name's Will. Yeah. I'm sorry. I was not exercising. I'm just a heavy breather. Are you hot today? Why are you not wearing anything but socks? You guys looking for a friend?
这个按钮坏了。你们去几楼？我要去三楼。哦，也许我按一下那个按钮我们就能直接去了。我其实不是要去哪一层。我只是搭电梯兜风。你只是在坐电梯，想认识几个人。我叫杰森。这是我的朋友肖恩。你叫什么名字，朋友？我叫威尔。好吧。对不起。我不是在锻炼。我只是呼吸比较重。你今天觉得热吗？你为什么除了袜子什么都没穿？你们俩在找朋友吗？
We're busy. We got to do a podcast. Welcome to... Oh, welcome to Smardless. That's it. Smart. What else? Smart. What else? Smart. What else? Smart. What else? What else? Smart. What else?
我们很忙。我们要录播客。欢迎来到……哦，欢迎来到 Smardless。就这样。Smart。还有什么？Smart。还有什么？Smart。还有什么？Smart。还有什么？还有什么？Smart。还有什么？
Oh my god, I'm so nervous. Let me see. Okay. Do we just go or do we practice once or... No, we're just going to do it. We're just going to do it. Okay. Okay.
哦天哪，我好紧张。让我看看。好吧。我们是直接开始还是先排练一次或者……不，我们直接开始。我们就直接开始。好吧。好吧。
Ready? Hey, smartless listeners. This episode has We're just gonna do it. Okay. Okay. Ready? Ha ha ha ha. Hey, smart list listeners. This episode is brought to you in part by our friends at Verizon. If you're wishing for the new iPhone 15 Pro with Titanium, you don't need to find a genie in a bottle or I don't know, steal an unsuspecting kid's birthday wish.
准备好了吗？嘿，smartless 的听众们。本期节目由……我们就直接开始。好吧。好吧。准备好了吗？哈哈哈哈。嘿，smart list 的听众们。本期节目部分赞助商为我们的朋友 Verizon。如果你一直想要带有钛金属外壳的新款 iPhone 15 Pro，你不需要去神灯里找精灵，或者我不知道，去偷一个毫无防备的小孩的生日愿望。
I get it, Sean. I get what you're doing there. For Verizon is making it easy to get Apple's latest and greatest with an amazing trade-in offer. Even if your current iPhone is seeing better days, may my phone is pristine, but you know some of us just aren't as careful. No judgment here though. Shot at you Sean, shot at you. That's I got it. And you got another one coming up too.
我懂，肖恩。我明白你在那里的意思。Verizon 正在通过一项惊人的以旧换新优惠，让你轻松拥有苹果最新、最棒的产品。即使你目前的 iPhone 已经大不如前，我的手机虽然崭新，但你知道我们当中有些人就是没那么小心。不过这里不予评判。隔空敬你一杯，肖恩，隔空敬你一杯。这就对了，我懂。而且你等会儿还有另一个。
Yeah. Hey look, you know Sean and I are well acquainted with the excellent service and offerings from Verizon, so believe me when I say this upgrade deal is one for the books. Get the new iPhone 15 Pro with Titanium on Verizon, plus Apple TV 4K and 6 months of Apple 1 on them with select phone trade-in and new line on select unlimited plans. That's over $1,100 in value, only on Verizon and network you can rely on. Visit a Verizon store or Verizon.com for full details. Offer ends November 15th, 2023 and is only available in the United States.
对。嘿，你看，你知道肖恩和我对来自 Verizon 的优质服务和产品非常熟悉，所以请相信我，这次的升级优惠绝对是史无前例的。通过指定的手机以旧换新并在指定的无限流量套餐中开通新线路，即可在 Verizon 获得带有钛金属的新款 iPhone 15 Pro，外加 Apple TV 4K 和 6 个月的 Apple One。总价值超过 1,100 美元，仅在你可以信赖的网络 Verizon 提供。访问 Verizon 门店或 Verizon.com 了解完整详情。优惠于 2023 年 11 月 15 日结束，仅在美利坚合众国提供。
I was just dropped any sweet little Denny who's as you know, is three off at school. And on the way there, he starts telling me this story is running a shirt. It's got an alien on it. He's going, I saw an alien. I said, you did? Yeah. Last night. No kid. Yes. And he go, really? Yeah. I saw an alien. It was in, it was in our home. Yeah. He was in the body. He was next to the body. I said, the alien used our body. Yeah. He said, do you go number, do you go peer poop? You go poop and he goes, no, he did a huge poop. I saw it really. So then he starts telling me this story. And the alien ends up in the toilet
我刚刚送了可爱的小丹尼去上学，你知道的，他三岁。在路上，他开始跟我讲这个故事，说一件衬衫。上面印着一个外星人。他说，我看到了一个外星人。我说，真的吗？对。昨晚。没有骗你。是的。他说，真的吗？对。我看到一个外星人。它在，它在我们的家里。对。它在身体旁边。我说，那个外星人用了我们的身体。对。他说，你会上号吗，你会上嘘嘘便便吗？你会大便，然后他说，没有，他拉了一个巨型便便。我亲眼看到，真的。然后他就开始给我讲这个故事。最后外星人进了马桶
and then they're kicking a soccer ball. And I go, what color is soccer ball? It's green, just the same as him and him family. And I said, okay, so he tells us this whole story and go, so then I start every time I keep relaying it back to him. Let me get this straight. So you see the alien and by the third time I go, so let me get this straight, the alien's inner bath
然后他们在踢足球。我问，足球是什么颜色的？是绿色的，跟他还有他家人一样。我说，好吧，于是他讲了整个故事，然后我说，所以我每次都把内容复述给他听。我来理清一下。所以你看到了外星人，到第三次的时候我说，我来理清一下，外星人在浴室里
and he goes, the end. He was done with the story. Okay. And then Jay, I start telling this story because he sees this building that one of the other boys kid, his buddy lives in. So we start getting into friends and what's the name of Archie's friend and his mom. And I said, what's the name of Mabel's daddy? And he goes, Sean, and I said, no, close. Yeah.
然后他说，完。他的故事讲完了。好吧。然后，杰，我开始讲这个故事，因为他看到了一栋楼，那是另一个小男孩、他的好朋友住的地方。所以我们开始聊起朋友，阿奇的朋友叫什么名字，还有他的妈妈。我说，梅贝尔的爸爸叫什么名字？他说，肖恩，我说，不对，接近了。对。
Might as well be. And he goes, and he goes Jason. I said, yeah, it's Jason. I don't believe it. I swear to God and we go through and then Amanda and Franny and blah, blah, blah, blah. And I go, yeah, and then remember we were at our friends house the other night for dinner and then Abel's other friend and then he goes, I don't like your story.
差不多也行。然后他说，他说是杰森。我说，对，是杰森。我真不敢相信，我向上帝发誓，然后我们聊过去，还有阿曼达和弗兰妮，巴拉巴拉巴拉。我说，对，然后还记得前天晚上我们在朋友家吃晚饭吗，还有梅贝尔的另一个朋友，然后他说，我才不喜欢你的故事。
I like my story better. I don't care at all. But right? Right kids. I'm still believing that there's an alien in the bathroom. my story better. This is a terrible. But right kids, I'm still believing that there's an alien in the bathroom. I know. Did you see the photos from, from where was that from Mexico? Yeah. I mean, yeah, are those real?
我更喜欢我自己的故事。我一点都不在乎。但是对吧？对吧，孩子们。我还是相信浴室里有外星人。我更喜欢我的故事。这太糟糕了。但是对吧，孩子们，我还是相信浴室里有外星人。我知道。你看到那些照片了吗，来自，那是来自墨西哥的吗？对。我是说，对，那些是真的吗？
The, I mean, they're obviously can't be real, but CBS and CNN and everyone's like reporting them. I should like, yeah, I thought that was like what news of the world used to do. Yeah, I can't believe that Sean's not doing this episode from Mexico City. I'm just realizing that when I rebooted right before we started recording, I lost all my questions for my guest. No way. Yeah, like what? Did you find them now?
我是说，它们显然不可能是真的，但 CBS、CNN 和每个人都在报道。我应该，对，我以为那是以前《世界新闻报》会做的事。对，我真不敢相信肖恩不是从墨西哥城录制这一集的。我刚意识到，就在我们开始录音前不久重启时，我把我给嘉宾准备的所有问题都弄丢了。不会吧。对，比如什么？你现在找到了吗？
No, I'm just... Why do you have more reboots than anybody? I don't know. I guess I'm technologically not gifted. I don't know what's going on. But you know what? I don't need them. I don't need them because where I'm deficient in technology, I am gifted in asking questions.
没有，我只是……为什么你比任何人都重启得频繁？我不知道。我想我大概没有什么电脑天赋吧。我不知道是怎么回事。但你知道吗？我不需要它们。我不需要它们，因为我在科技上有所欠缺的地方，我在提问上却很有天赋。
Not verbosity. Okay. All right, here we come. Here we go. Do I do still have my intro? Sorry, Sean, did you, are we on a… No, I'm going to say, do you want me to tell you something while you look for them or no? Well, we can wait are we on a, I'm gonna say do you want me to tell you something while you look for them or no?
不是指啰嗦。好吧。好了，我们来吧。我们开始了。我还有我的开场白吗？抱歉，肖恩，你，我们是在……不，我要说，你想让我边找边告诉你点什么，还是不用？好吧，我们可以等，我们在，我要说你想让我边找边告诉你点什么，还是不用？
We can wait until we're done with your break. Sean just found the, the drive-through for Cinebon right around the corner of the house. Yes, are we interrupting breakfast or anything? No. Is it really Cinebon? No, it's a peanut butter sandwich, peanut butter and jelly sandwich. By the way, listener,
我们可以等你的休息时间结束。肖恩刚发现在房子拐角处就有一家 Cinnabon 的免下车餐厅。是的，我们打扰你吃早餐了吗？没有。真的是 Cinnabon 吗？不是，是一个花生酱三明治，花生酱果酱三明治。顺便说一句，听众朋友们，
we're on a Zoom yesterday with about 20 people. And, Oh geez. We'll, we'll ask Sean, hey, Sean, it's about five o'clock. And we close to dinner. He's like, yeah, let's go in and see what's cooking. So he goes into the kitchen and there on the stove is, forget what you were talking about. That it was some sort of a fish thing, but there's like a bacon is being fried to contribute to the sauce. There's some sort of a fish thing, but there's like a bacon is being fried
我们昨天开了一个大约有 20 人的 Zoom 会议。然后，哦天哪。我们会问肖恩，嘿，肖恩，现在大约五点钟了。我们快吃晚饭了吗。他说，行，我们进去看看有什么好吃的。于是他走进厨房，炉子上正放着……忘了你刚才在说什么来着。那好像是什么鱼类料理，不过里面还在煎培根来给酱汁增添风味。那好像是什么鱼类料理，不过里面还在煎培根
to contribute to the sauce. There's some sort of a cheese dish that's, I said, do you have family over or friends or something, or is it just Thursday? Yeah, that was a lot of food. So you have like a full, you have a full meal. Yeah, yeah, just that's the only meal. For me, I'll every night. Yeah, yeah. Just that's the only meal. Full meal every night.
来给酱汁增添风味。还有某种奶酪菜肴，我说，你是有亲戚朋友来家里做客，还是今天只是星期四？对，那真是相当多的食物。所以你就像是有一顿，有一顿丰盛的正餐。对，对，那就是唯一的一餐。对我来说，每天晚上都这样。对，对。那就是唯一的一餐。每天晚上都吃丰盛的正餐。
Yeah, almost every night, yeah. But, but, but that's because I don't usually eat like fish or something healthy. I'll eat like something healthy-ish during the day so that I can have like spaghetti and meatballs or something at night. Do you put bacon in that too? No, no. Were you so worried about the health content of the fish that you had to throw the bacon at it?
对，几乎每天晚上都这样，对。但是，但是，那是因为我平时不怎么吃鱼或者健康的东西。我会在白天吃点比较健康的东西，这样晚上就能吃肉丸意面之类的了。你那里面也放培根吗？不，不。你是对鱼的健康程度这么不放心，所以非得往里加点培根吗？
Yes. Yes. By the way, Jay, when was the last time we got an invite for a dinner? I mean, he has a nice meal every night. Every night. about the health content of the fish that you had to throw the bacon at it. Yeah, like you've asked. By the way, Jay, when was the last time we got an invite for a dinner? I mean, he has a nice meal every night. Every night. I just kind of figured like,
是的。是的。顺便说一句，杰，我们上一次收到晚宴邀请是什么时候？我是说，他每天晚上都吃得很丰盛。每天晚上。对鱼的健康程度这么不放心，所以非得往里加点培根吗？对，就像你问过一样。顺便说一句，杰，我们上一次收到晚宴邀请是什么时候？我是说，他每天晚上都吃得很丰盛。每天晚上。我只是觉得……
y'all want to go in your own corners. You don't need to folksy that up to excuse your rudeness, okay? Folksy. I'm so excited that we have one of the world's great talkers today. This isn't, I'm getting, I'm entrowing my guest. This man is electric with his words, his guitar, and his charisma.
你们都想待在自己的小世界里。别用那种乡土气息的话来掩饰你们的无礼，好吗？乡土气息。我很高兴我们今天请到了世界上最会聊天的人之一。这不是，我正在，我正在引出我的嘉宾。这个男人用他的言语、他的吉他和他的个人魅力散发着电光石火般的能量。
Today's guest is one of the most famous and successful athletes alive today. When he played, he was as dominant as he was compelling. He was fiercely competitive and never boring. He has an unbelievable amount of trophies and records in his sport, but what he's done for the Caucasian Afro and the Enkort microphones will never be matched. Please welcome the winner of 17 Grand Slam's A Great Guitar, is a good golfer and a new friend of mine, the one and only John McEnroe. Oh my gosh. Mr. McEnroe. Good morning John.
今天的嘉宾是当今在世最著名、最成功的运动员之一。当他还在场上时，他的统治力正如他的引人注目一般强大。他有着极其强烈的竞争心，而且绝不无聊。他在他的运动生涯中获得了令人难以置信的奖杯和纪录，但他为高加索阿福罗头和恩科特麦克风所做出的贡献将永远无法被超越。让我们有请 17 次大满贯得主、吉他高手、出色的高尔夫球手以及我的新朋友，独一无二的约翰·麦肯罗。哦天哪。麦肯罗先生。早上好，约翰。
Wow. Very nice, Jason. Thank you. That's probably a show, right? I shortened it a little for you because I knew Will was gonna go it's my career And he did he beat me. It's a race with him. He's bright He said once I knew about the the Curlier the guitar when you say grand slams in guitar. I was like, yeah, it's gotta be I didn't know you play guitar. Hi John nice to meet you. Nice to meet you. Yeah, yeah, I loved you by the way and brought I hadn't been to a play for years. Your performance was amazing. You came to the show. I did. I
哇。非常好，杰森。谢谢你。这大概算是一场秀吧？我为你稍微缩短了一点，因为我知道威尔会说“这是我的职业生涯”，他确实这么说了。这简直是在跟他赛跑。他很聪明。他曾经说过，一旦我知道了……吉他的卷曲度，当你提到大满贯和吉他时，我就想，对，肯定是这个。我不知道你会弹吉他。嗨，约翰，很高兴认识你。很高兴认识你。对，对，顺便说一句，我非常喜欢你，我以前……我已经好几年没看话剧了。你的表演太棒了。你来看了演出。我去了。我
tried to come back to say hello. They wouldn't let me in. No. Yeah. That's very kind of you. Thank you, pal. Thank you for coming. I didn't realize that that greater piano player, man. That was something that wasn't that stunning. Can you believe that he has talent? player, man, that was something that wasn't that stunning. Can you believe that he has talent? I knew he had talent, but that was off the charts. That's very sweet. Thank you. Yeah, classically trained pianist, never, never, never knew it.
试着去后台跟你打招呼。他们不让我进。没有。是的。你太客气了。谢谢你，老兄。谢谢你来看。我没想到你还是个钢琴高手，伙计。那真是不一般，太惊艳了。你能相信他有这方面的天赋吗？高手，伙计，那真是不一般，太惊艳了。你能相信他有这方面的天赋吗？我知道他有天赋，但那简直突破天际了。太甜了。谢谢你。对，受过古典训练的钢琴家，从来、从来、从来都不知道。
But this is about Mr. McIrl. Thank you, John, for coming up. This is about Mr. McIrl. Now, John, do you play piano as well as guitar? No. I do not, although Jimmy Webb, who is a famed songwriter and pianist, tried to teach me the guitar a couple of times. We traded tennis lessons for piano lessons.
但这是关于麦肯罗先生的。谢谢你，约翰，你能来。这是关于麦肯罗先生的。那么，约翰，你弹钢琴和弹吉他一样好吗？不。我不会，尽管著名词曲作家兼钢琴家吉米·韦布曾尝试教过我几次吉他。我们用网球课交换钢琴课。
Yeah. And it's just, it wasn't for you. It's easier on the fingertips, isn't it? I love the piano, but I prefer the guitar. I try to get all my kids to play piano. They did, but they didn't stick with it. I said, stick with it. It'll be good for you. Maybe someday you'll be on Broadway kicking ass. Yeah.
对。然后就是，这不太适合你。对指尖的压力更小一些，对吧？我喜欢钢琴，但我更喜欢吉他。我曾试图让我所有的孩子都学钢琴。他们学了，但没有坚持下来。我说，坚持下去。这对你们有好处。也许有一天你们会在百罗汇大显身手。对。
Winnithonies. But no. Yeah. Exactly. Maybe someday you'll be wearing two compression sleeves and icing your fingers every night. Exactly. John doesn't think the don't think the guitar strings hurt your fingertips. Yeah. That that that that was my problem with it. And also like could you ever get carpal tunnel or any kind of like, tendonitis? I've been lucky, actually. I probably don't play enough to get carpal tunnel, but you got to build up, the calluses,
赢得托尼奖。但并没有。对。没错。也许有一天你会戴着两个加压护袖，每天晚上给手指冰敷。没错。约翰不觉得吉他弦会弄痛指尖吗？对，那，那，那曾是我遇到的问题。而且还有，你有没有得过腕管综合征或者任何类似肌腱炎的毛病？我很幸运，其实。我可能弹得还不够多，所以没得腕管综合征，但你得建立起老茧，
like you do on with your, my tennis hand. You had to do the same thing when you grip a racket. So that takes a while. But I got over that. And you know, at least this is one of the few things I'm improving at, a guitar playing. Did you ever get tennis elbow? I was about to ask the same.
就像你在我的网球手上做的那样。你握球拍时也得做同样的事情。所以这需要花一些时间。但我克服了。而且你知道，至少这是我在不断进步的少数几件事情之一，弹吉他。你得过网球肘吗？我正要问这个。
You know, generally speaking, I had issues at times with the elbow, but never real bad. How about golf elbow? Have you been, have you been there? I have not had golf elbow. I just have, why am I playing this dumbass game sometimes? Elbow.
你知道，一般来说，我有时肘部会有问题，但从来不是很严重。高尔夫球肘呢？你得过，你得过那个吗？我没有得过高尔夫球肘。我只有，为什么我有时会玩这个蠢游戏？肘部。
Oh, John, that's not true. You're a good golfer. We play the cup of times. You and you're not unlike what you said about guitar. I feel like you're getting better at golf. I feel like you're more consistent. I've seen you miss some some shortpots, sure. I could have a video. Wait, you guys always play together. Yeah, I have a video currently on my phone of John missing a putt on the ninth hole over there. Are they any fell to the ground and took off all his clothes and protest every time I play. I don't like the, I don't like how much time you're spending in New York, though. It's not great for our golf outings.
哦，约翰，这不是真的。你是个优秀的高尔夫球手。我们一起打过几次球。你，正如你对吉他所说的那样，我觉得你在高尔夫上越来越好了。我觉得你更稳定了。我见过你错失一些短推，当然。我可能有一段视频。等等，你们总是聚在一起打球。对，我手机里现在就有一段视频，是约翰在那边的九号洞错失推杆的画面。每当我打球时，他们就会倒地并脱光衣服以示抗议。不过，我不喜欢你在纽约花太多时间。这对于我们的高尔夫远足可不太妙。
Well, sometimes Jason, I do have to work. Yeah, man, you know, the US open was, you know, the big one for us in hometown. It's great, but we missed you well, that Augusta though. I know, I know. I wish I could have, as you knew, I had a, I had a dear friend of mine passed away, so I couldn't make it. But we're going to do it again, same crew, and we're going to do it up and get down there. I'm so excited.
好吧，有时杰森，我确实得工作。是的，伙计，你知道，美国公开赛对我们来说是家乡的大赛，这很棒，但我们很想你，威尔，还有奥古斯塔那次。我知道，我知道。我真希望我能去，正如你所知，我有一位挚友去世了，所以我没能去。但我们会再去的，还是原班人马，我们要好好玩一把，去那儿大干一场。我太兴奋了。
Now, also what's keeping you in New York is your great tennis academy. That started when? I would say about 12 years ago, the last 10 of which we've also started a charity arm, which is called the Johnny Mac Tennis Project, which is, you know, we're constantly trying to raise money so we can get more kids to play this great sport. It's too unaffordable, it's not accessible enough, it's too expensive, especially in New York.
另外，把你留在纽约的是你伟大的网球学院。那是从什么时候开始的？我想大概是 12 年前吧，在过去的 10 年里，我们还设立了一个慈善分支，叫做“约翰尼·麦肯罗网球计划”，你知道的，我们一直在努力筹集资金，以便让更多的孩子能够打这项伟大的运动。这项运动太负担不起了，它的可及性还不够，太贵了，尤其是在纽约。
So it's an ongoing battle, but we're making progress. If somebody wanted to contribute to that, how would they go about doing something like that? It's a 501c3, go on the web and internet and go to Johnny Mac Tennis Project and anything you can give would be incredible. But we just had a program and we do, we do a comedy night every year, which is great.
所以这是一场持续的战斗，但我们在取得进展。如果有人想为此捐款，他们该怎么做呢？这是一个 501(c)(3) 非营利组织，登录网络和互联网，前往 Johnny Mac Tennis Project，你能提供的任何帮助都将是不可思议的。但我们刚刚有一个项目，而且我们每年都会举办一个喜剧之夜，非常棒。
Jason should give 10, great. Jason, give 10, grand right now. Well, this is a 10, grand right now. It's a shot and Sean, will you match me? Let's go. That's 30 right here. Oh, come on. Come on. You're breaking out. You're, you're tennis academy was going through your tennis academy is, is charitable in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, charity work there basically or philanthropic work where you are identifying kids that wouldn't otherwise maybe be drawn to tennis or have access to tennis and you're giving them that right through scholarships and whatnot. Absolutely. And we have a lot of programs.
杰森应该捐 1 万，太棒了。杰森，现在就捐 1 万。好吧，这是现在就捐 1 万。这是挑战，肖恩，你会跟我匹配吗？走吧。这里就是 3 万。哦，别这样。别这样。你正在破产。你的，你的网球学院正在经历，你的网球学院是，是慈善的，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，在，那里的慈善工作或慈善事业基本上就是你在发掘那些平时可能不会被吸引去打网球或无法接触到网球的孩子，你通过奖学金等方式把网球带给他们。绝对的。我们有很多项目。
We go to public schools and we bring them in. But this is also a for profit place. And I work for someone. This is city on land. And the people put 20 million dollars into it. We're putting an additional 15 to add another 10 courts. So this is an incredible place. But at the same time, there's 90% I'd say the people or people that went to schools like I went to high school The Ivy League high schools that pay the bills You know they come and play once or twice a week so that we have a chance to do enough and raise enough that we can get the 1%
我们去公立学校，把他们带进来。但这也是一个营利场所。我为某个人工作。这是 City on land。人们向其中投入了 2000 万美元。我们正在额外投入 1500 万美元来增加另外 10 片球场。所以这是一个不可思议的地方。但与此同时，有 90% 我会说是那些人，或者是去过像我上过的高中那样学校的人，那些常春藤盟校的高中，他们支付了账单。你知道，他们每周来打一两次球，这样我们就有机会做足够的事并筹集到足够的资金，让我们能够照顾那 1%。
You know unfortunately What 99% can't afford it. Yeah, right right? Well, was that like, John, for you speaking of high school? Because I know now, I mean, it kind of, and again, please correct me if I'm wrong, but it seems to me that kids who played tennis when they were growing up and they were young. The idea of going to like an all tennis academy started with Nick Bollitterry, is that right? Sort of that dedicated thing where the kid you started to hear about. But for guys like you who were like right on the before that,
你知道，不幸的是，99% 的人负担不起。对，对，对？约翰，说到高中，对你来说那是什么样的？因为我知道现在，我的意思是，它有点，再次纠正我如果我错了，但似乎从小就开始打网球的孩子们。去那种全网球学院的想法是从尼克·博利泰里开始的，对吗？就是那种专注的模式，你开始听到这种说法。但对于像你这样处于那个时期之前的家伙们，
right before that generation, were you playing tennis every day on Long Island, were you playing, were Queens or, what was that like for you? I grew up in Queens. The best thing that ever happened to me was not going to a ball of Terry's type camp. I would equip the game when I was 16 or 17. I
就在那代人之前，你是在长岛每天打网球吗，你是在打，还是在皇后区，对你来说那是什么样的？我在皇后区长大。发生在我身上最好的事情就是没有去博利泰里那种类型的训练营。我可能在 16 或 17 岁时就会放弃这项运动了。我
loved to play other sports. All studies show both physically and mentally. It's healthier for kids to play other sports. This idea that you got to go all in and soccer or basketball as a bunch of can you say bullshit on this? You can say, yeah. Total BS. You can say fucking bullshit. Yeah, you can say fucking bullshit. I'll get to that shortly when you ask me a lousy question.
喜欢打其他运动。所有研究都表明，无论在身体上还是精神上，让孩子多参加其他运动更健康。这种认为你必须全情投入足球或篮球的想法，有一群……你能在这里说“胡扯（bullshit）”吗？你可以说，是的。完全是胡扯。你可以说“他妈的胡扯（fucking bullshit）”。是的，你可以说“他妈的胡扯”。当我回答你一个糟糕的问题时，我等会儿就会说到这个。
I got one for you. But the truth is, is that what I base, my beliefs on or what this academy is all about, that you know, you should play other sports, and you should come to this a little later. Tennis players are peaking later than they ever did. I think college is an experience that not only you get to play as a team, potentially, if you're in a sport, you get to grow up a little bit, and also have some fun before you
我有一个问题要问你。但事实是，我的信仰或这个学院所代表的一切是，你知道，你应该参加其他运动，你应该晚一点再来接触这个。网球运动员的巅峰期比以往任何时候都要晚。我认为大学不仅仅是一个能让你以团队形式参赛的经历（如果你从事某项运动的话），你还能成长一点，并且在
work your way into a profession, and you'll be more prepared to handle it. So I completely disagree with what they do most often. Right, because John, the idea that like, not just as an athlete, but also as a person, as a human being, if you come in and you turn pro when you're 17 or something, and if maybe you have success, and again, like you said, you're not peaking yet,
步入职业生涯之前享受一些乐趣，你会更有准备去应对它。所以我完全不同意他们大多数时候的做法。没错，因为约翰，那种认为不仅作为一名运动员，而且作为一个普通人、一个人类，如果你在 17 岁左右就进入并转为职业球员，如果可能取得成功，而且就像你说的，你还没达到巅峰，
but you have success, all that kind of pressure, everything that goes along with that, the traveling, being away from home, being away from family, your support group, it seems to me that be, especially for tennis, it'd be pretty tough to deal with all that if you were young. For every person you hear that succeeds is a million that don't, you know, not everyone's Carlos Alcaraz, he's one in a billion, uh, inter- Yeah.
但你取得了成功，所有的压力，随之而来的一切，四处奔波，远离家乡，远离家庭，远离你的后援团，在我看来，特别是对于网球来说，如果年纪轻轻就要应对这一切，会非常艰难。你听到每一个成功的人背后，都有数百万不成功的人，你知道，并不是每个人都是卡洛斯·阿尔卡拉斯，他是十亿分之一，呃，对——
And he's just a freak, he's an incredible player. But most kids have no business doing that. And college now has become more competitive, and now they can offer money, which is, you know, was unheard of. You can actually, you know, go after a guy and offer him something for the NIL stuff. The NIL stuff. I mean, most obviously he's going to football and basketball, but at least allows kids that otherwise would have nothing in college
而且他简直是个怪才，他是个不可思议的球员。但大多数孩子根本不适合那样做。现在大学竞争变得更加激烈了，而且现在他们可以提供资金了，这在以前是闻所未闻的。你实际上可以，你知道，去争取一个球员并为 NIL（姓名、形象和肖像权）的事情提供一些东西。NIL 的事情。我的意思是，最明显的当然是去美式橄榄球和篮球，但至少它允许那些在大学里原本一无所有的孩子
to think maybe I should wait a couple of years. Yeah. John, why do you attribute like you talk about Alcarez? Like these guys are hitting the ball and who is it that Medvedev played him right? They hit the ball so hard. I have to, I mean, it's not like, not like us.
去想，也许我应该再等几年。约翰，为什么你认为——你谈到阿尔卡拉斯？像这些家伙击球太狠了，是梅德韦杰夫跟他打的对吧？他们击球太猛了。我得说，我的意思是，这不像是，不像是我们。
No, but I mean, like, well, that's what. I'm just saying like, we were dinersores. Well, but I mean, you guys were every bit as big and as strong, is it just the racket? I mean, you guys were playing, I can't believe what you were able to do with the size of the racket that you guys were playing with. Why is it bigger now? Oh, yeah, it's bigger now.
不，我的意思是，好吧，这就是。我只是说，我们是恐龙。好吧，我的意思是，你们当时个头和力量一点也不差，难道只是球拍的问题吗？我的意思是，你们在打球时，我简直不敢相信你们用那种大小的球拍能打出那样的水平。为什么现在的球拍更大？哦，是的，现在更大。
It's lighter now. I didn't know that. Look at that thing. Yeah. That's what I played with till I was 23, which is, you know, about you add another 40%. That's the difference in power and the size of it. So the sweet spots a lot bigger. So that's allowed kids at my academy. I'm at my academy right now that hit 12, 14 year olds, hit the ball harder than me. John, John just showed us his wooden rack. Was that, did you win Wimbledon with that racket?
现在更轻了。我以前不知道。看看那个东西。对。这就是我一直用到 23 岁的球拍，你知道的，你要再加上 40%。这就是力量和尺寸上的差距。所以甜区要大得多。这使得我学院的孩子们——我现在的学院里有 12 岁、14 岁的小孩，击球比我还重。约翰，约翰刚刚向我们展示了他的木制球拍。那是，你用那种球拍赢得过温网吗？
Like that kind of racket? I did. I was one of the only records I still have. And I think I will always have it is I'm the last male player to win a major with a wooden racket. Wow. That's right.
就像那种球拍？是的。那是我保留的仅有的球拍之一。我想我会一直留着它，我是最后一个用木制球拍赢得大满贯的男子球员。哇。没错。
What if somebody made a storm or it came back out of the scene with one of those rackets? Do you think how long do you think they'd last? You just, you can't compete with the one. If you played one event, Carlos Alcaraz could play with with with anything. He is amazing. What about what about what about Federer? Who's who's been who's yeah game Federer seemed to me had like such and I remember I've over the years you know watched a lot of matches of his that you've called many many. He has you
如果有人造出那种球拍或者拿着这种球拍重新出现在赛场上会怎样？你觉得他们能撑多久？你根本无法用木制球拍竞争。如果你打一项赛事，卡洛斯·阿尔卡拉斯可以用任何东西比赛。他太惊人了。那费德勒呢？费德勒的比赛……费德勒给我的感觉是，我记得这些年来我看过很多他打的比赛，你解说过多场。他真的
really like the way he played his style and his he was so graceful and he's I don't know, how would you describe it? He's the most beautiful player I've ever seen. You know, I idolized Rod Lavor. He was an awesome, he's like the bridge and a cough of tennis. As I would describe him, where, you know, you look at Rafael Nadal, that's not your typical,
很喜欢他打球的方式、他的风格，他那么优雅，而且他，我不知道，你会怎么形容他？他是我见过最美丽的球员。你知道，我把罗德·拉沃尔视为偶像。他是了不起的，他就像网球界的……我该怎么形容他呢，你知道，当你看到拉斐尔·纳达尔时，那不是你典型的、
or prototypical tennis player, his body. You know, he looked, you know, like bigger up top when we grew up there, like don't lift, right? You know, you don't want to get, you know, that's a memo. Yeah. I was like, don't worry. You know, who do you think you'd match up best with today? Oh, yeah.
或原型般的网球运动员，他的身体。你知道，他看起来，你知道，在我们长大时上半身更壮硕，就像“别举重，对吧？”你知道，你不想变得，你知道，那是当时的备忘录。对。我当时想，别担心。你觉得今天你能和谁对阵得最好？哦，是的。
I mean, like another lefty? No. You mean, who would I play like? Or who would I play? Who would you, yeah. If, I mean, like another lefty, no. You mean who would I play like? Or who would I match? Who would you, yeah, if apples were to apples today as far as age goes and equipment goes, who do you think you'd have the most entertaining match with? Like the match. Well, the dream would be to play Roger Federer at Wimbledon.
我是说，就像另一个左撇子吗？不。你是说，我会像谁？或者我会跟谁打？你会，是的。如果今天是年龄和装备都完全对等的情况，你觉得你会和谁进行一场最具娱乐性的比赛？就像那场比赛。好吧，梦想是在温网对阵罗杰·费德勒。
The nightmare would be to play Rafael in theale at Rolling Garros on clay, even though I grew up on clay. That was my best surface, so I turned pro. But he's, you know, what he did was insane. Why don't people still serve in volley like you used to? I need to find that so far. I feel like Becker was like the last one to do it, right? That's correct. Yeah. You know what? They changed, they changed the court speeds, they slowed it down and wimbled and they did the same at the like Indian Wells or the US Open. Actually, US Open is fairly quick. So you're seeing it come back a little bit with Alcharez and people always imitate the top guys, but you know, the explosion necessary to come in point after point. I don't think people
噩梦是在罗兰·加洛斯的红土上对阵拉斐尔·纳达尔，尽管我是在红土上长大的。那是我最好的场地，直到我转为职业球员。但他，你知道，他所做的一切简直疯狂。为什么现在人们不像以前那样频繁地发球上网了？我需要找到原因。我觉得贝克尔好像是最后一个这么做的，对吧？没错。是的。你知道吗？他们改变了，他们改变了场地速度，在温网放慢了速度，在印第安维尔斯或美网也是如此。实际上，美网相当快。所以你看到阿尔卡拉斯又开始恢复这种打法了，人们总是模仿顶尖球员，但是，你知道，连续得分所需的爆发力。我想人们
realize that takes a physical toll. Right. So it's easier to serve big. These guys are bigger, Mevadav 6.6. The average player's gone from, you know, when I was six. He's six six. So the average player has gone from five 10,
没有意识到这会付出身体代价。对。所以大力发球更容易。这些家伙更高大，梅德韦杰夫身高 6 英尺 6 英寸。平均身高已经从，你知道，当我……他身高 6 英尺 6 英寸。所以平均身高已经从 5 英尺 10 英寸、
five nine to 10, two, six two, six three even. You know, joke of it's a six two and a half. Murray, six three. It you know, joke of it's a six two and a half, Murray, six three. It used to be six one, that would be Sampress, Fetter and the Doll. But, you know, players are getting more athletic taller. So if you come on it with these rackets,
5 英尺 9 英寸上升到 6 英尺 2 英寸、甚至 6 英尺 3 英寸。你知道，德约科维奇是 6 英尺 2 英寸半，穆雷是 6 英尺 3 英寸。以前是 6 英尺 1 英寸，比如桑普拉斯、费德勒和纳达尔。但是，你知道，球员变得越来越有运动天赋、越来越高。所以如果你拿着这些球拍上网，
the ball's coming back faster, unless you stand 20 feet beyond the baseline, like Mevadev. Yeah, that was amazing. And so it's tougher to get close to the net. Right. We'll be right back. Big thanks to Zip Recuder for their support.
球回来的速度会更快，除非你像梅德韦杰夫那样站在底线后 20 英尺的地方。对，那太惊人了。所以想靠近网前就更难了。对。我们马上回来。非常感谢 ZipRecruiter 对我们的支持。
Guys, you know who I'm grateful for? The two guys listening right now recording this for me, I love them very much, Bennett and Rob. They're like my family. We couldn't do the show without them. And every single day, I say a prayer for them, and I love them, and I have photos of them on my refrigerator.
伙计们，你们知道我最感激谁吗？就是此时此刻正在听节目并为我录音的这两个家伙，我非常爱他们，本内特和罗布。他们就像我的家人一样。没有他们，我们做不出这个节目。每天，我都会为他们祈祷，我爱他们，我的冰箱上还贴着他们的照片。
We love you too, Shawnee. Thank you. Love you, Shawnee. Thank you. It takes a team of people to make this show successful, just like it takes a solid team to make any business successful. So if you're hiring, how do you find the best people
我们也爱你，肖尼。谢谢。爱你，肖尼。谢谢。制作这个节目需要一个团队的努力，就像让任何商业成功都需要一个坚实的团队一样。所以如果你正在招聘，你该如何为你的团队找到最优秀的人才
for your team, Zip Recruiter? And right now, you can try it for free at ziprecruiter.com slash smartless. Here's why you'll be grateful you tried Cypricrooter for your hiring. Zipricrooter uses smart technology to scan thousands of resumes to find the most qualified people for your job. For these two, we went through thousands of resumes and nobody was interested. And we landed, and I mean landed on these two. We still love you, Sean. Mmm.
呢？ZipRecruiter。现在，你可以在 ziprecruiter.com/smartless 免费试用。以下是你应该尝试使用 ZipRecruiter 进行招聘的原因。ZipRecruiter 使用智能技术扫描数千份简历，为你的职位找到最合格的人才。对于这两个人，我们翻阅了数千份简历，没有人感兴趣。最后我们选中了这两个人——我是说真正选中了他们。我们依然爱你，肖恩。嗯。
Wow, that was a wet one, right through the microphone. You'll also get great match notifications. Zippercruder lets the most qualified people for your job know they are a great match for it and encourages them to apply. See why so many business owners and hiring managers are thankful for Zippercruder. Four out of five employers who post on Zippercercuder get a quality candidate within the first day. We'd be super grateful if you could go to this exclusive web address right now to try Zippercuder for free, zippercuder.com slash smartless.
哇，那声音听起来湿漉漉的，直接喷到麦克风上了。你还将获得极佳的匹配通知。ZipRecruiter 会让最适合你职位的人知道他们非常匹配，并鼓励他们申请。来看看为什么那么多企业主和招聘经理都对 ZipRecruiter 充满感激。在 ZipRecruiter 上发布招聘信息的雇主中，五分之四的人在第一天内就能招到高质量的候选人。如果你现在能访问这个独家网址免费试用 ZipRecruiter，我们会非常感激：ziprecruiter.com/smartless。
Again, that's zippercuder.com slash SMA RTLES Cyphercooter, the smartest way to hire. Our thanks to Amazon Prime for supporting this episode of SmartLess. You probably already know Amazon Prime offers a range of services like Prime Video, Amazon Prime Music, and Prime Fast Free Shipping. But let's take it one step further. It's this very collection that can help you pursue your passions and get more out of whatever you're into or perhaps whatever you're just starting to get into. Prime helps you get more out of your interests. Take jazz, for example, right? I can do jazz, and I'm doing jazz hands right now. Are you a fan? Great. You can browse Prime Video for a jazz doc or a jazz-centric movie or listen to the sweet sounds of smooth jazz on Amazon
再次重申，网址是 ziprecruiter.com/SMA RTLES。ZipRecruiter，最聪明的招聘方式。感谢 Amazon Prime 对本期 SmartLess 播客的支持。你可能已经知道，Amazon Prime 提供了一系列服务，例如 Prime Video、Amazon Prime Music 和 Prime 快速免费配送。但让我们更进一步。正是这一系列服务可以帮助你追求自己的热情，并从你的任何爱好中获得更多，或者也许是你刚刚开始涉足的领域。Prime 能帮你从兴趣中获得更多收获。以爵士乐为例，对吧？我可以做爵士乐，我现在正在做爵士手势。你是它的粉丝吗？太棒了。你可以在 Prime Video 上浏览爵士乐纪录片或以爵士乐为主题的电影，或者在 Amazon
Prime music. And hey, while listening to a jazz playlist, you might just be inspired to up your knowledge and use Prime shipping to get a book about the legendary Miles Davis delivered to your door. There are tons of scenarios where Prime could make life a little richer that for me to list them all would be impossible. From shopping to streaming to saving, it's on Prime. Visit Amazon.com slash prime
Prime Music 上聆听顺滑爵士乐的美妙旋律。嘿，在听爵士乐播放列表的同时，你可能会受到启发去提升你的知识，并使用 Prime 配送将一本关于传奇人物迈尔斯·戴维斯的书送到你家门口。有太多场景可以让 Prime 让生活变得更丰富，要我全部列举出来是不可能的。从购物、流媒体到省钱，尽在 Prime。访问 Amazon.com/prime
to get more out of whatever you're into. Hey gang Jason here, November is diabetes awareness month. A time to bring attention to diabetes. So let's let's talk a little bit about that. Managing diabetes requires a lot of effort and unfortunately a lot of people living with it don't feel understood because not many people know what it really takes to manage the condition. Well that's where Medtronic Diabetes comes in. Medtronic makes devices to manage diabetes and they're very passionate about supporting the community, which is why they've launched their Blue Balloon Challenge to raise awareness. The balloon represents the mental load and constant decision making that people living with
来从你的各种爱好中获得更多。嘿，各位，我是杰森，11 月是糖尿病意识月。这是一个呼吁关注糖尿病的时期。所以让我们，让我们来聊聊这个。管理糖尿病需要付出巨大的努力，不幸的是，许多与之共存的人并没有感到被理解，因为没有多少人真正知道管理这种疾病需要付出什么。这就是美敦力糖尿病（Medtronic Diabetes）发挥作用的地方。美敦力制造用于管理糖尿病的设备，他们对支持这个社区充满热情，这就是他们发起“蓝气球挑战”以提高意识的原因。气球代表了生活在糖尿病之中的人们所面临的心理负担和不断的决策。
diabetes are faced with. It's a constant balancing act trying to keep blood sugars in range while living their life. Medtronic diabetes wants you to join the challenge and help them spread awareness and support for the diabetes community. So grab a blue balloon and try to keep it in the air while doing everyday things in your life. Tag MedTronic Diabetes on social media and use the hashtag blue balloon challenge.
在过好生活的同时，努力将血糖维持在正常范围内，这是一个持续的平衡过程。美敦力糖尿病希望你加入挑战，帮助他们传播对糖尿病社区的意识和支持。所以，拿一个蓝气球，试着在做生活中的日常事情时让它保持在空中。在社交媒体上标记 Medtronic Diabetes 并使用话题标签 #blueballoon challenge。
We can all come together to help make the invisible visible. Visit medtronicdiabetes.com slash smartless to learn more. That's medtronicdiabetes.com slash smart list to learn more. That's MedTronicDiabetes.com slash smart list. All right, back to the show. You know what's funny? You're talking about these guys are coming on the scenes Alcatraz as I call them because you know I just like put a twist on it. You know what I mean? Jay, you're amazing. Sean's not with me. You saw him right about the day. I was sitting down and I'm with him.
我们齐心协力，就能让隐形的被看见。访问 medtronicdiabetes.com/smartless 了解更多信息。那是 medtronicdiabetes.com/smartless。也就是 MedTronicDiabetes.com/smartless。好了，回到节目中。你知道有什么好笑的吗？你刚才提到阿尔卡拉斯这些家伙开始崭露头角，就像我称呼的那样，因为你知道，我只是给它加了点新意。你知道我的意思吗？杰，你太棒了。肖恩没跟我在一起。你那天看到他了，我正和他坐在一起。
Yeah, I'm just really happy. You talking about these new guys should come on. So Alcarazza's come on the last two years and he's just been an absolute, he's exploded like kind of seemingly out of nowhere. I mean, for us, for, you know, I'm not a huge, I don't follow it. The minutiae of tennis. But. Well, he's number one in the world.
对，我真的很高兴。你谈到这些新人开始崭露头角。所以阿尔卡拉斯在过去两年里崭露头角，他简直是一个绝对的，他以一种似乎突如其来的方式爆发了。我的意思是，对我们来说，对，你知道的，我不是一个超级粉丝，我不关注。网球的那些琐事。但是。好吧，他是世界第一。
He is. No, I'm just saying before I didn't watch, I didn't know about it. I didn't know that he was the guy. He was in the pipeline.e of tennis. But, well, he's number one in the world. He is. No, I'm just saying before I didn't watch. I didn't know about, I didn't know that he was the guy. He was in the pipeline. He was coming. I just, all of a sudden he was there and he was incredible. But John, you did the same thing. I mean, what I'm getting to is, I remember distinctly,
他是。不，我只是说之前我没看，我不知道。我不知道他就是那个人。他一直在酝酿中。他要来了。我只是，突然之间他就出现在那里了，而且他太不可思议了。但是约翰，你也做了同样的事。我的意思是，我要说的是，我清楚地记得，
I remember being up in Northern Canada watching you and Bjorn Borg play in those unbelievable, when I was a kid, those unbelievable matches from Wimbledon. And everybody's like, who's this guy? And you know all this stuff. He was like, he's, he's brash. He's from New York. He doesn't give a shit. He, he won Wimbledon. And then he, if I can win, got pizza with his pals or so. I still remember that story again. Part of the pretenders. You part of the right. I'm really among other people. But the afro and the afro and the headband though was just so hostile.
我记得在加拿大北部看你和比约恩·博格在那些令人难以置信的比赛中对决，当我还是个孩子的时候，温网那些不可思议的比赛。每个人都说，这家伙是谁？你知道所有这些。他当时，他很傲慢。他来自纽约。他根本不在乎。他赢得了温网。然后他，如果我能赢的话，就和他的死党去吃披萨什么的。我依然记得那个故事。属于那些叛逆者。你属于对。我确实……除了一些其他人之外。不过，阿福罗发型和发带看起来真是太有攻击性了。
We don't want to hear about parting with the pretenders. Well listen, who would you rather party with? The bunch of old farts that you know, they did dinner that we weren't sure I had a go to or you know, some rock stars. So I don't think that was the top one. You know, I went to Wimbledon when I was 18. I was sent to play the juniors. And I broke through and qualified and made it to the semis of the main draw. And that completely changed my life. I didn't realize, you know, what Wimbledon men except when I saw my, the guy you mentioned, my great rival, Bjorn
我们不想听关于和叛逆者一起派对的事。好吧，听着，你宁愿和谁一起派对？那一群老古董，你知道的，他们办了晚宴，而我们甚至不确定我是不是非得去，还是说一些摇滚明星。所以我不认为那是顶级的。你知道，我 18 岁时去了温网。我被派去参加青少年组比赛。我取得了突破，通过了资格赛，并打入了正赛的半决赛。这彻底改变了我的人生。我不知道，你知道，温网意味着什么，直到我看到我提到的那个家伙，我的伟大大敌，比约恩
Borg. And I remember seeing him play a few matches when I was like 15 before I played there. And like hundreds of girls ran on the court. And it was like, oh my God, this is like tennis is version of Beatle Mania, Borg, the people, I go, I wanna be a tennis player. So I gotta get some of that. And so, and then I, I wanna just mention this because to practice what I preach,
·博格。我记得在我大概 15 岁还没去那儿打球之前，看他打过几场比赛。几百名女孩冲进球场。那种感觉就像是，哦天哪，这简直是网球版的披头士狂热，博格，那些人，我当时想，我想成为一名网球手。所以我也得弄点那种名气。然后，然后我，我只想提一下这个，为了践行我所宣扬的理念，
which is I actually went to college after that. I played professionally all through the summer. I was 21 in the world when I entered Stanford. Wow. So, uh, that's crazy. It's unheard of if anyone's even above 500. So I felt like I wasn't ready emotionally and wanted to experience being part of a team and going to Stanford. And I think that was good for me in my career as it ended up. And then you fast forward a couple of years, those are the matches where I played Borg two years in a row 8081. And so that was like the greatest, you know, a great time for tennis. I was lucky. I came into what turned out to be a really important time
这实际上是我在那之后去上大学的原因。整个夏天我都在进行职业比赛。当我进入斯坦福大学时，我在世界排名第21位。哇。所以，呃，这太疯狂了。如果有人能排在前500名以外，那都闻所未闻。所以我当时觉得自己在情感上还没有准备好，并想体验作为团队一员的感觉以及去斯坦福上学。回过头来看，我认为这对我后来的职业生涯很有帮助。然后时间快进几年，就是我连续两年与博格对决的那些比赛，即80和81年。所以那就像是最棒的，你知道的，网球的黄金时期。我很幸运。我正好赶上了网球运动蓬勃发展的关键时期
where tennis was really growing. I mean, if you had told me that golf without rate tennis, the way it does now is on the net worse, I would laugh at you in the 80s. And so we haven't done nearly enough as a sport. We were at the same ratings as basketball. And it's absurd. How far have we gone the wrong?
当时网球真的很受欢迎。我是说，如果你在80年代告诉我，高尔夫在网球没有普及的地方，现在其网络热度会更差，我一定会笑话你的。所以作为一项运动，我们做得还远远不够。我们曾拥有与篮球相同的收视率。这太荒谬了。我们究竟走错了多远？
Pickle ball. If I hear a pickle ball, one more goddamn time. I'm on to. I'm going to fuck with you on the pickleball. That's your cue, Sean. Go for it, buddy. He's just going to say pickleball thought, but, but, but you play a different kind of pickleball. Well, boy, Joe, I played a kind with, when I played tennis, you know, me and Andre Aguicy played along with, you know, Michael Chang was on my team in Andy Roddick. So it was like tennis players playing. So it wasn't as painful as having to put up with some, or a college player who didn't make it in tennis. And now it's one of the best pickleball players in the world. And it's a wiffle ball.
匹克球。如果我再听到一次“匹克球”这个该死的词，我就要……我要拿匹克球跟你开玩笑了。该你上场了，肖恩。上吧，老兄。他本来只想说匹克球的，但是，但是，但是你打的是另一种匹克球。好吧，乔，我打的那种……当我打网球时，你知道的，我和安德烈·阿加西一起打过，你知道的，迈克尔·张在我的队里，还有安迪·罗迪克。所以那是网球运动员在打。因此，这不像不得不忍受某些人，或者一个在网球界没混出名堂的大学球员那样痛苦。而现在他成了世界上最好的匹克球选手之一。这不过是个塑料网球。
I agree. Wiffle ball was outside. And when you're a kid growing up, I did in Queens. It's not the same as baseball. No, it's not his trash. I think it's total trash. I used to play paddle. I used to play paddle tennis in the beaches in Venice for years. That's a better game. At least you play with the tennis ball that's had the air taken out of it. But the fucking pickle ball. I like it. I like it. Oh, of course you do. Everybody does. It's like it's like when people starting getting the racquetball, you can fact guys can stand in the middle. They don't even have the fucking walk. The box is the racquetball. Pick a ball is the fucking same. You want to do shit. You can't wait. I can't wait till these fucking rich assholes have
我同意。塑料网球原本是在户外玩的。当你还是个在皇后区长大的孩子时，我就在那里玩过。它和棒球可不一样。不，它根本比不上。我觉得它简直就是垃圾。我以前玩过板式网球。我曾在威尼斯海滩玩过多年的沙滩板网球。那是更好的运动。至少你是用那种放过气的网球来打的。但那个该死的匹克球。我喜欢它。我喜欢它。哦，你当然喜欢。大家都喜欢。这就像……这就像人们开始玩壁球时一样，那些家伙可以站在中间。他们甚至连走都不用走。球场就是壁球场。匹克球也他妈的一样。你想搞点事情。你等不及了。我等不及看这群该死的有钱混蛋
to pay over their stupid. What was that over there? We have a fucking period. We have a debt. Pick them all apart. Pick them all apart. I'll tell you the happiest people around are the doctors because a lot of people have played. It's better to do something than nothing. So I'll go with that.
去为他们愚蠢的东西买单了。那边那个是什么？我们有个该死的时期。我们有个债务。把匹克球批得一无是处。把匹克球批得一无是处。我告诉你，最高兴的人是医生，因为很多人都在玩。做点总比什么都不做好。所以我赞成这一点。
But I didn't like yesterday. What's that? I worked on my legs yesterday. That means he squatted down to the stove, opened it up, pulled the pie out. No, he had to down to the stove, opened it up, pulled the pie out. No, he had to put his feet around a fucking huge, he had a 10 pound bag of checks mix, and he had to use his feet to hold the ground. Now, he opened it. Hey, John, talk about what, I mean, obviously winning, this is for the folks out there that
但我昨天不喜欢。什么？我昨天练了腿。这意味着他蹲到炉子旁，打开它，把派拿出来。不，他不得不蹲到炉子旁，打开它，把派拿出来。不，他必须把双脚踩在一个巨大的……他有一大袋10磅重的咸味小吃，他必须用脚把地面固定住。现在，他打开了。嘿，约翰，聊聊，我是说，很显然，获胜，这是对那些
don't play tennis, but something that you could you could you could talk to them about that's that's applicable. The the gain you'd get from winning versus losing, because everybody has experience with winning and losing. How you've probably had to develop a muscle early on that could turn a negative into a positive and try to try to gain from it. Was was losing, you know, losing tangible gain for you at times that you can speak about? Well, obviously, as a father of six and having grown up being told that losing builds character and you learn more from losing than you do with winning,
不打网球的人说的，但有些事你可以、可以、可以跟他们聊聊，而且是切实相关的。获胜与失利带来的收益，因为每个人都有过赢和输的体验。你可能很早就必须培养出一种能力，能把消极转化为积极，并试图从中获益。失败，你知道的，对你来说有时是一种实实在在的收获吗，你能谈谈吗？嗯，显然，作为六个孩子的父亲，从小就被灌输“失败培养性格，你从失败中学到的比从胜利中学到的更多”这种观念，
that there was something that was inrained in me at a young age. And I do believe that it's true that you can sort of take a step back and that it does help you in a lot of ways. Not just on a tennis court. So that's what I try to tell the kids that are at my academy, try to nurture them. It's hard though, because you feel like the last place you want to be is on a tennis court when you're getting your ass kicked
这种想法在我很小的时候就根深蒂固了。而且我相信这是真的，你可以退一步思考，这在很多方面确实对你有所帮助。不仅仅是在网球场上。所以这就是我试图告诉我的网校孩子们的话，试着去培育他们。不过这很难，因为当你被别人
by someone. Yeah, no, no. Especially if you ever got to the stage where you're playing at US Open in Arthur R. State and what would you be like a dream come true for any professional tennis player and then you get toasted by someone. So my problem was is that at a certain point in my career,
打得落花流水时，网球场绝对是你最不想待的地方。对，没错，没错。特别是如果你曾打到过这样的阶段：你在美网的阿瑟·阿什球场比赛，对于任何职业网球运动员来说，这就像是梦想成真，然后你却被某人给横扫了。所以我的问题是，在我的职业生涯某个特定阶段，
I think late 20s, I started getting more fearful of losing and not sort of embracing the idea that you need to learn from it as opposed to facing up to it. And that hurt me. And I felt like I was a lesser player from that point forward. I had more of a fear and a fear of failure sort of gotten the way a little bit too much. You always have to battle that as well.
我想大概是在快30岁的时候，我开始变得更加害怕失败，而不再去拥抱那种需要从失败中学习的理念，反而选择去回避它。这伤害了我。我觉得从那个时候起，我变成了一个更差的球员。我有了更多的恐惧，对失败的恐惧在某种程度上阻碍了我太多。你总是不得不与这种心态作斗争。
Did you end up getting on top of that? Or is that still something that like, do you take that out of the golf course? You take that into, you know, experimenting with music. Like have you gotten on top of it and factor in losing as an acceptable result? I've, you know, I go by the belief now that it's better to try and fail than not try it all.
你最后克服那个问题了吗？或者这仍然是某种……比如，你会把这带到高尔夫球场上吗？你会把这带到，你知道的，对音乐的探索中吗？你克服它了吗，并将失败视为一个可以接受的结果？我现在，你知道的，秉持这样一种信念：尝试并失败，总比什么都不尝试要好。
Yeah. Um, early on when I was doing commentary, I stopped playing boys like 30 years ago, the main tour. I played a champion seniors tour for 25 more years. But at that time, I started to get some positive feedback about my commentary. And it's once, at a certain stage, people would come up to me, you're a better commentator, then you are, we're a player, and I like, bolt-shipped, okay? That's fucking real shit.
对。嗯，早期我做解说的时候，我大概在30年前就退出男子主巡回赛了。我又在元老常青巡回赛打了一晃25年。但那时，我开始收到一些关于我解说的积极反馈。到了某个阶段，人们会走过来对我说：“你作为一个解说员，比你当球员时要优秀得多。”而我的反应就像是：真他妈扯淡，好吧？这可真他妈是实话实说。
It would really make me angry for quite a long time, for years. And then I realized, I thought to myself, I took a step back once and I said, wait a minute, I thought to myself, I took a step back once and I said, wait a minute, if I, they think I'm a better commentator than I was a player. They never saw you play. Well, that'd be one possibility. Or else, hey, maybe, maybe I am a pretty damn good commentator. And I should take that as a compliment. So, you know, just sure. Yeah. And I have. But it's, it took a long time. I guess it would be the long answer to your question,
这真的会让我生气很长一段时间，好多年。然后我意识到，我心里想，我曾经退后一步说，等一下，我心里想，我退后一步说，等一下，如果我……他们觉得我比当球员时是个更好的解说员。他们从没看过你打球。嗯，那是一种可能性。或者，嘿，也许、也许我真的是个很棒的解说员。我应该把这当作一种赞美。所以，你知道的，当然。对。而且我已经接受了。但这花了很长时间，我想这是对你那个问题的长篇大论的回答，
was that it took a lot of experiences that you referred to. You know, the love of music has a hobby. Getting a second chance with a second marriage that worked out far better than the first. Trying to be the proper role model as best as possible for my kids is often as possible. I got six kids between my two marriages appreciating life that I've been pretty damn lucky. That's what I try to give back at my academy. And even when I do with commentary working
那就是这经历了我所提到的很多经历。你知道的，把对音乐的热爱当作一种爱好。在第一段婚姻失败后，迎来了第二段婚姻的第二次机会，结果比第一段好得多。尽可能地为我的孩子们做一个合格的榜样，而且要尽可能经常这样做。我在两段婚姻中一共育有六个孩子，我很感激自己一直以来都非常幸运。这就是我试图在我的网校中回馈的东西。甚至当我在巡回赛中从事解说工作时，
around the players, that, you know, I'll do next week when I go to labor cup, which is our version of the rider cup. And try to just be around the guys, and if I can help them that little bit, 5%, 10%, that could make the difference, hopefully. So I've got a much better attitude than I did, although I think that some of the things that I used to hide my fear of failure, which was showing anger, and said, like, sit in their start crying. You know, that I don't think we were brought up to be, let's cry on the tennis court.
围绕着这些球员，你知道的，下周我去拉沃尔杯（这是我们版本的莱德杯）时就会这么做。试着陪伴这些小伙子们，如果我能稍微帮到他们一点——哪怕是5%、10%——希望这能带来改变。所以我的心态比以前好多了，尽管我认为我以前用来掩饰对失败的恐惧的一些方法，比如表现出愤怒，而不是坐在那一声不吭地开始哭泣。（你知道的，我不认为我们被教育成可以在网球场上哭泣的人。）
So, right, right. A lot of that time, that was manifested and sort of turning into anger. God forbid, I thought I had a decent sense of humor. And I would think of something funny, like, that was going on the court, but I felt like when I grew up, it was like, you gotta keep intense.
所以，对，对。很多时候，这种情绪表现出来并转化成了愤怒。天哪，我以为自己还有点幽默感。我会想到一些有趣的事情，比如当时在球场上发生的事，但我觉得自我长大起，那种氛围就是：你必须保持专注。
You can't. You'll lose your edge if you do anything. Now you see guys that are out there like Fed or I was like, how the hell is this guy look like he's so happy to be out there? Yeah. Or you know, Alcaraz, the guy smiling, I'm gonna just you wait.
你不能。如果你做任何其他事，你就会失去优势。现在你看到那些球员，比如费德勒，我当时就想：这家伙怎么看起来这么高兴能上场打球？对。或者你知道的，阿尔卡拉斯，那个总是面带微笑的家伙，我跟你说，你就等着吧。
Just give it a couple of years. You'll be miserable like the rest of us. Yeah. But I watched you, I think we talked about this once. I feel like, John, I wish that you would commentate on other sports because I know you're a big sports fan. And I'm like, I wish you would go on and commentate on football and basketball and hockey. And you know, that would be fucking, you should have you ever thought about that?
再过几年。你就会像我们其他人一样痛苦了。对。但我看你打球，我想我们以前讨论过这个。我觉得，约翰，我真希望你能去解说其他运动，因为我知道你是个超级体育迷。我当时就想：我真希望你能去解说美式橄榄球、篮球和冰球。你知道的，那肯定他妈的……你有没有考虑过这一点？
Didn't you say once you were going to, or you did do it for basketball? It's like a side-mocha pass Like, like, Peyton and Eli do. I did, I did, I did Peyton and Eli just this past Monday. Yeah. Yeah, they don't count. Peyton and Eli don't count, they're. They're pretty damn good at that. No, I love this.
你不是说过一次你要去，或者说你确实为篮球解说过了吗？就像副频道传送一样，就像佩顿和伊利做的那样。我做过，我做过，我上周一刚和佩顿和伊利合作过。对。对，那些不算。佩顿和伊利的不算，他们……他们在那方面做得相当不错。不，我喜欢这个。
I love this. No, no, no, but I actually last year when I saw it, I was like, oh my God, this is absolutely perfect for me and my brother. Yeah. To do on the tennis. Let's unleash us. Let us do it. Oh, it's already been done.
我喜欢这个。不，不，不，但实际上去年我看到的时候，我就想：哦，天哪，这对我跟我兄弟来说绝对是绝配。对。在网球上这么干。让我们大展身手吧。让我们来干吧。哦，这已经有人做过了。
What? Okay, so what? Yeah, I'm working with the concept. And as far as answering your question, yes, I was a few years back. I was going to do a next game. Unfortunately, my dad passed away, like literally right around that time, so he wasn't able to happen. There was a time, I don't know if you remember this,
什么？好吧，那又怎样？对，我正在构思这个概念。至于回答你的问题，是的，几年前。我本打算去解说下一场比赛。不幸的是，我父亲去世了，就像是在那个时间点前后，所以没能实现。曾几何时，我不记得你是否还记得这个，
it was probably 15 years ago, Dennis Miller ended up getting the job, but they said Monday night football, they want someone who's not a football player. Oh, right. And they want it maybe bringing three or four guys for three or four games each, and I go, oh my God, that's
那大概是15年前的事了，丹尼斯·米勒最终得到了那份工作，但他们当时说《周一橄榄球之夜》想要一个不是橄榄球运动员的人。哦，对。他们可能想找三四个家伙，每人解说三四场比赛，我当时就想：哦，天哪，这
absolutely perfect. This would be unbelievable because I love sports like you said and I don't, I'm no football expert, but I know enough about it to sort of at least give my two cents like a fan. And then I called my agent and he's like, ah, they, you know, they went with Dennis Miller and I go, what did they say when you mentioned my name? I didn't mention it. I didn't think you'd get it. I'm like, what?
绝对是完美契合。这简直难以置信，因为就像你说的，我热爱体育，而且我虽然不是橄榄球专家，但我对它了解得足够多，至少可以像个球迷那样发表一下我的拙见。然后我打电话给我的经纪人，他说：“啊，他们，你知道的，他们选了丹尼斯·米勒。”我说：“当你提到我的名字时，他们是怎么说的？”“我没提。我以为你不会接。”我说：“什么？”
What a guy. You got a deal on him, huh? So he was done. So I'm so fired. Even though he helped me issue with the TV deal, so I'm like, what are you doing? But I'm not saying I would have gotten it anyway. But now, of course, you feel like in a certain way
真是个好人。你真跟他签了个好合同啊，哈？所以他被解雇了。虽然他帮我搞定了电视合同，所以我当时想：你在搞什么鬼？但并不是说我本来就一定能得到这份工作。不过现在，当然，你在某种程度上会觉得
I don't want to be like walk in and be like yeah here I am I can do you know football and you know some football player who You know wants a job and needs it. I you know, I feel a little weird about that So maybe the talk show format what I was gonna do radio I'd like to talk show by the way Yeah, thank you for both. You were both came on it. It was 19 years ago. Unbelievable. Oh my God. Unreal. That was a long. That was a long time. Right when CNBC got started, right? Wasn't CNBC? Yeah. They wanted to do. As a matter of fact, I filed Dennis Miller and they were trying to get, you know, usually
我不想就像那样走进去说：“嘿，我在这儿，我能解说你知道的橄榄球”，然后某个需要工作的橄榄球运动员……你知道的，我对那感觉有点怪怪的。所以也许谈话节目的形式，我本打算做广播的，顺便说一句，我喜欢谈话节目。对，谢谢你们俩。你们俩都上过节目。那是19年以前的事了。难以置信。哦，天哪。太不真实了。那是好久以前了。就在CNBC刚开播的时候，对吧？不是CNBC吗？对。他们想要做……事实上，我跟着丹尼斯·米勒，他们当时试图让，你知道的，通常
people turn off CNBC at four o'clock, right? You know, and Charles Gross. Yeah, Sean, you should know when John did his program, our mutual for all four of us, no Meredith. Walker. Yeah, I worked for John. Yeah. Oh, they didn't know that. Yeah, I love Meredith.
人们在四点钟就会关掉CNBC，对吧？你知道的，查尔斯·格罗斯。对，肖恩，你该知道，当约翰做他的节目时，我们共同的……我们四个人，还有梅雷迪思·沃克。对，我为约翰工作过。哦，他们不知道这个。对，我喜欢梅雷迪思。
And that's how we end up doing it. And I still got, I think I still got the racket that you gave everybody was a guest assigned racket. Dunlop was a guest assigned racket. Dumb lot bracket I got. And just you guys. Oh, shit, just us. No, not me. Oh my god.
这就是我们最终参与其中的方式。我好像还留着你送给每个嘉宾的签名球拍。邓禄普签名字球拍。我得到了一个邓禄普球拍。只有你们。哦，操，只有我们。不，不是我。哦，天哪。
I'll check the mail again. I'm fascinated by John, you know, I'm, these guys know I'm fascinated by medicine and medical things and when I went whenever an athlete comes out I was asked what's the worst injury because I'm, I'm, you know, the repetitiveness of like Jason was talking about earlier about just the repetitiveness nature of especially tennis of the constant back and forth. What was your worst injury and what did you do to take care of it because I, it is like, like, the theater, I know these guys joke, but it is every single day doing the same movements over and over again, takes a toll on your body. So how did you, how did you play for so many years?
我得再去查查邮件。我对约翰很着迷，你知道的，这几位都知道我对医学和医学方面的事情很着迷，每当有运动员退役时，我总是会问最严重的伤病是什么，因为我，你知道的，正如肖恩刚才所说的那样，那种重复性，尤其是网球那种不断来回的动作所带来的重复性质。你经历过最严重的伤病是什么？你是怎么处理的？因为我知道，就像，虽然这些家伙在开玩笑，但日复一日地做着同样的动作，会对你的身体造成损害。所以你是怎么做到打这么多年的？
What was your regimen like if you got hurt? Well, first of all, I'm gonna knock on wood because I'm pretty lucky. I've never had a surgery. Wow. Amazing. So that already is lucky when you hear these horror stories of the football players. I remember they asked Joe Montana recently, who's the greatest quarterback ever?
如果你受伤了，你的日常训练是怎样的？首先，我要敲敲木头，因为我非常幸运。我从来没做过手术。哇。太神奇了。所以当你听到橄榄球运动员那些可怕的遭遇时，你已经算很幸运了。我记得不久前有人问乔·蒙塔纳，谁是有史以来最伟大的四分卫？
He said, damn, Reno, and they go, you don't mean like Tom Brady or Patrick Gohomes, and how would it be different for you? And he was like, because they protect the quarterback more. 27 surgeries later, he's had 27. John L. Ways had 27 to 30 surgeries. So these poor souls take way more of a beating. The worst injury I ever had, I tore
他说：“该死的，是马里诺。”他们说：“你不是指汤姆·布雷迪或帕特里克·霍姆斯吧，这对你来说有什么不同吗？”他的意思是，因为他们对四分卫的保护更多。27次手术之后，他做过27次。约翰·埃尔韦做过27到30次手术。所以这些可怜的家伙承受了多得多的摧残。我经历过最严重的伤病，我撕裂了
my hamstring, and this was in the seniors, they're not the main tour, and you have chronic shoulder problems. I tore my meniscus twice the last five years without, I didn't do surgery, and I recovered. But I was fortunate. I was taught in a way that it didn't put a lot of strain on my body. Look at Nadal, the way he swings it, everything it, everything. It's like the home run swing. So I think, you know, that you're more likely to get hurt. But I was... He did get injured, right? In a period there, that wasn't he quite...
我的腿筋，这是在元老赛时，不是在主巡回赛，而且你有慢性的肩膀问题。在过去五年里我的半月板撕裂过两次，我没有做手术，而且我恢复了。但我很幸运。我受到的训练方式使得我的身体没有承受太大的压力。看看纳达尔，他挥拍的方式，所有的一切，一切。就像全垒打挥拍一样。所以我想，你知道的，你更有可能受伤。但我……他确实受过伤，对吧？在那段时期里，难道他不是很……
He's been injured a handful of times, but, you know, he's got a great team around him that keeps him going. I don't know how he still does it at his age, but he's had numerous injuries. Bar's backers had 12 surgeries. A lot of guys have a lot of surgeries and it's cost them. Hips is the worst part.
他受过几次伤，但是，你知道的，他身边有一个出色的团队让他一直坚持下来。我不知道他在这个年纪是怎么做到的，但他受过无数次伤。鲍里斯·贝克尔做过12次手术。很多家伙做过很多次手术，这让他们付出了代价。臀部是最糟糕的部位。
I think the hip is the thing I've struggled with the most, and it's all connected, obviously. So, you know, I had a, you know, mainly when I was younger, and most successful was pretty much tennis. You know, you do running, sprinting, that type of stuff, not a lot of weight work. I've I played doubles, which no one does anymore. And as I started doing weights, I actually didn't help me. And off court training, I
我认为臀部是我与之斗争最多的部位，而且这一切显然都是相互关联的。所以，你知道的，我曾经，你知道的，主要是在我年轻的时候，最成功的时候基本上都是打网球。你知道的，你做跑步、短跑，诸如此类的事情，没有做很多负重训练。我打双打，现在没人这么做了。当我开始进行力量训练时，实际上并没有对我有帮助。场外训练我
just enjoyed to like work out to generally try to keep, you know, reasonably fit. So that's, you know, I've been pretty fortunate all in all compared to most people. You've got to be the only like Uber champion of any sport that has never had a surgery. That's got a new record by itself. That's unbelievable to me. You and Kel Ripken. No, but you Kel Ripken's.
只是喜欢锻炼来大致保持，你知道的，相当不错的体型。所以这就，你知道的，总的来说，比起大多数人，我算是相当幸运的。你一定是个没有做过手术的任何运动的超级冠军。这本身就打破了纪录。这对我来说太不可思议了。你和卡尔·瑞普肯。不，但是卡尔·瑞普肯的……
I've had like 17 months. The only person ever that reached number one in the world who has the same size arm, left arm is right arm. I used to try to copy Rod Laver because his arm was like, pop by. And I was like, I would squeeze balls like hours and hours a day when I was a kid. And you know, do any type of,
我有过大约17个月……唯一一个达到世界第一但左右手臂一样粗的人，左臂和右臂一样粗。我以前试图模仿罗德·拉沃尔，因为他的手臂肌肉非常发达。我还是个孩子的时候，就会连续几个小时不停地捏球。你知道的，做任何类型的、
anything I could do to, well, I'm even going where you're going. I'm just saying it's nice that you can, now Sean can finally relate. Yeah, I'm just saying it's nice that Sean can finally relate. I'm just saying, squeeze balls and I just perk up. Most athletes, anyone, especially if you're doing something with one arm, 95% of the time, or more, I had a one hand at back end. I could not figure out why nothing changed.
任何我能做的事情……好吧，我甚至没跟上你的思路。我只是说，很高兴肖恩终于能感同身受了。对，我只是说很高兴肖恩终于能感同身受了。我只是说捏球让我来了精神。大多数运动员，任何人，尤其是如果你95%以上的时间都在用一只手臂做某事，我有单手反拍。我怎么也想不通为什么没有什么变化。
So it's bizarre, but the body was pretty resilient all in all. I never, I played tennis off and on, and I don't really play that much anymore, but I used to, and I used to love playing some for very stages. And I always prided myself because you would talk, I always pride myself on having one handed backhand. Cause I grew up in an era when everybody wanted to have, like in the 80s, everybody was trying to get that, you know, to hand it backhand and print brackets and
所以这很奇怪，但总的来说身体相当有韧性。我从来没有……我断断续续地打网球，现在其实已经不怎么打了，但我以前打过，而且我以前在不同的阶段非常喜欢打。我一直为自己感到骄傲，因为你刚才说过，我一直为自己拥有单手反拍而感到骄傲。因为我是在那个每个人都想拥有的时代长大的，就像在80年代，每个人都试图去打那种，你知道的，双手反拍，并购买大拍面球拍和
all that kind of shit. And I was like, no, I want to play it more gracefully. And anyway, I just want to say, I think you'd really approve of my backhand, John. Go ahead. Hey, the bad news is that if I had a young kid now and said, should you do one or two, I would tell them to. Of course. It's more. Well, you can, you, and the way they hit off the back foot more and obviously you can
诸如此类的各种操蛋玩意儿。而我说：“不，我想打得更优雅一些。”总之，我只想说，约翰，我觉得你真的会赞赏我的反拍。说吧。嘿，不好的消息是，如果我现在有个小孩，问我是该用单手还是双手，我会告诉他们……当然。更多的是……好吧，你可以，你可以，而且他们更多地利用后脚发力击球，显然你可以
take balls up higher, especially when you're younger, but even as you're older, because he so much spin that it makes more sense to use the two hands. It's actually better for you physically because you're using both sides of the body more. It doesn't look as cool. And the other thing is one hand backhand looks so graceful. But I will say it's funny if all this sort of years of playing and taking tennis lessons when I was a kid and whatever, then when you watch these guys the way they play now, I'm like, what game are they playing?
把球击得更高，尤其是当你年轻的时候，甚至当你年纪大了之后，因为他带有那么多的旋转，所以使用双手打球更有意义。从生理上讲，这其实对你更好，因为你更多地动用了身体的两侧。虽然看起来没那么酷。另一件事是，单手反拍看起来太优雅了。但我要说的是，有趣的是，经历了所有这些年的打球和在小时候上网球课等等之后，每当你看这些家伙现在打球的方式时，我都会想：他们到底在打什么比赛？
Because the way they hit their body, where they're at with relation to the ball, where they're grip now, all that stuff is so different. Absolutely. I mean, I played with one grip. Now these guys, you know, have huge changes than they're back in a forehand grip. They seem to do it effortlessly and it's like learning a language, you know, if you learn it, it's quite easier when you're young. They're moving the racket as they play this.
因为他们击打身体的方式、他们与球的相对位置、他们现在的握拍方式，所有这些都太不一样了。绝对的。我是说，我以前只用一种握拍方式。现在这些家伙，你知道的，在反拍和正拍握拍之间有巨大的改变。他们似乎毫不费力地就能做到这一点，这就像学习一门语言，你知道的，如果你在年轻时学习它，就会容易得多。他们在比赛的同时还在调整球拍。
And what did I see during the US Open? One of the players actually took his racket, walked it up to his coach, handed the two on and asked him to restring it while he continued playing with a different racket. Well, they bring six or eight rackets on the court and they're always complaining like the coach fucked up. You know, it's their fault. You know, you got to blame someone other than yourself. So you give it to him.
我在美网期间看到了什么？其中一位球员竟然拿着他的球拍，走向他的教练，把球拍交过去并要求重新穿线，同时他继续用另一把球拍比赛。好吧，他们会带六到八把球拍上场，而且他们总是抱怨教练搞砸了。你知道的，那是教练的错。你总得怪罪除自己以外的人。所以你把它交给他。
You told me it should be 50, too. I'll get the fucking thing and put it at 48. But did you ever hand a racket to a coach and ask him to restring it during one of your matches? No. Well, first of all, I didn't travel with the coach back when I played, but second of all, I brought like six rackets in a bag,
你告诉我应该是50磅的。我要去把这破玩意儿调成48磅。但你在某场比赛中曾经把球拍交给教练并要求重新穿线吗？没有。好吧，首先，我打球的时候出场比赛不带教练，但其次，我会在包里带大约六把球拍，
but I'd have like four different tensions to sort of, you know, be, have available in case it was, you know, humid in case of all was flying heavy, whatever. These seem to bring all these same tension, which I don't quite understand. And the stringers are like millionaires now. We didn't restring rackets every five seconds. These guys string rackets, I remember San Chris,
但我会有大概四种不同的穿线磅数，以确保在天气潮湿时、在球飞得沉时、或在任何情况下都有备无患。现在的这些球员似乎带的全是相同磅数的球拍，这我有点不太理解。而且那些穿线师现在都成了百万富翁。我们可不会每隔五秒钟就重新穿一次球拍。这些家伙穿球拍……我记得桑普拉斯，
he broke out six rackets to a practice session. He used one of them for like an hour and then he go, I'm, all right, Mac, I'm done. And I go, okay. And then he give the string a restring all six. I go, why are you restring all six? He didn't even use five of them. Why do you think most sports are more tolerant of players having outbursts than tennises? I feel like you kind of got the short string on that to go back to strings.
他在一次训练课上拿出了六把球拍。他用其中一把大约一个小时，然后说：“行了，麦克，我打完了。”我说：“好吧。”然后他让穿线师把这六把全重新穿线。我问：“你为什么要把这六把全重新穿线？其中五把你连碰都没碰过。”为什么你认为大多数运动对球员情绪爆发的容忍度比网球更高？我觉得在这方面你吃了个闷亏（回到穿线的话题）。
Obviously, things are more accepted now, but at the time, people are looking at you like, oh my God, what is he doing complaining about that call? Why? It's so not okay. Okay, now other sports, it's fine. Why is that? Well, first of all, if you put a microphone in the middle of the field in a football game,
显然，现在大家对这些事的接受度更高了，但在当时，人们看着你的眼神就像是：“哦，天哪，他在为那个判罚抱怨什么？”为什么？这太不可接受了。好吧，现在在其他运动里，这完全没问题。为什么会这样？首先，如果你在橄榄球比赛的球场中央放一个麦克风，
something tells me they're not saying hello, how are you? I'm good. And basketball, they control it. In baseball, we used to love when the manager would go up to the park, kick dirt and his pants. That was incredible. Then I go out there and I go, you missed a call. And I'm like, you know, till the hunt, all of a sudden, you know.
直觉告诉我，他们绝不是在说“你好，最近怎么样？我很好”。而在篮球比赛中，他们会加以控制。在棒球比赛中，我们以前最喜欢看教练走到场上，踢着泥土弄脏裤子。那太不可思议了。然后我走到场上说：“你漏判了一个。”而我……你知道的，直到……突然之间，你知道的。
Yeah. And we will be right back. Smartlis has brought to you in part by all birds. Guys, I think I've mentioned this before, but I have all birds on of the same thing. I'm a fan of the same thing. I'm a fan of the same thing. I'm a fan of the same thing. I'm a fan of the same thing. I'm a fan of the same thing. I'm a fan of the same thing. I'm a fan of the same thing. I'm a fan of the same thing. I'm a fan of the same thing.
对。我们马上回来。SmartLess部分赞助商为Allbirds。伙计们，我想我以前提过这个，但我穿着Allbirds……我也喜欢同一款鞋。我是同一款鞋的粉丝。我是同一款鞋的粉丝。我是同一款鞋的粉丝。我是同一款鞋的粉丝。我是同一款鞋的粉丝。我是同一款鞋的粉丝。我是同一款鞋的粉丝。我是同一款鞋的粉丝。我是同一款鞋的粉丝。
I'm a fan of the same thing. I'm a fan of the same thing. I'm a fan of the same thing. I'm a fan of the same thing. I'm a fan of the same thing. I'm a fan of the same thing. I'm a fan of the same thing. I'm a fan of the same thing.
我是同一款鞋的粉丝。我是同一款鞋的粉丝。我是同一款鞋的粉丝。我是同一款鞋的粉丝。我是同一款鞋的粉丝。我是同一款鞋的粉丝。我是同一款鞋的粉丝。我是同一款鞋的粉丝。
I'm a fan of the same thing. I'm a fan of the same thing. I'm a fan of the same thing. I'm a fan of the same thing. I'm a fan of the same thing. I'm a fan of the same thing. I'm a fan of the same thing. I'm a fan of the same thing. I'm a fan of the same thing. I'm a fan of the same thing. I'm. The right shoes can take an outfit from good to great, and all birds elevates your everyday style
我是同一款鞋的粉丝。我是同一款鞋的粉丝。我是同一款鞋的粉丝。我是同一款鞋的粉丝。我是同一款鞋的粉丝。我是同一月款鞋的粉丝。我是同一款鞋的粉丝。我是同一款鞋的粉丝。我是同一款鞋的粉丝。我是同一款鞋的粉丝。我……一双对的鞋子可以让一套穿搭从普通变得出彩，而Allbirds通过
with timeless comfort and supreme versatility. Like they're all new courier, with nods to a classic silhouette for undeniable appeal and made from 100% organic cotton. All birds makes the most out of sustainable materials like leather made from plants, sugarcane, and tree fibers. Materials so natural, one might even say they're super natural. I've been wearing my tree dashers the most.
永恒的舒适感和极致的多功能性提升了你的日常风格。就像他们全新的Courier鞋款，向经典轮廓致敬，具有不可抗拒的吸引力，且采用100%有机棉制成。Allbirds充分利用了可持续材料，比如植物皮革、甘蔗和树纤维。这些材料如此天然，甚至有人会说它们是“超自然”的。我穿得最多的是我的Tree Dashers。
I wear tree dashers to the gym, I wear tree dashers to the store, I wear tree dashers everywhere. They're so unbelievably comfortable and I have them in two colors which I would tell you when I'm colorblind. Everyday comfort delivered, all birds all new courier, elevate your super natural style at allbirds.com today and use code SmartLess for free socks with your purchase. Don't forget to use our code to show your support for the show. That's all birds, A-L-L-B-I-R-D-S dot com code SmartLess.
我穿着Tree Dashers去健身房，穿着Tree Dashers去商店，穿着Tree Dashers去任何地方。它们简直舒服得不可思议，我有两种颜色，虽然对于一个色盲来说，我本可以告诉你这些。日常舒适，一触即达。Allbirds全新Courier鞋款，今天就在allbirds.com提升你的超自然风格，结账时使用代码SmartLess即可获赠免费袜子。别忘了使用我们的代码来表达你对节目的支持。网址是allbirds.com，代号SmartLess。
This episode is brought to you in part by WeWork, the world's leading flexible space provider. The world of work has changed, right? Whether fully remote, in office, or somewhere in between, people are looking for spaces that inspire, connect, and help with productivity and collaboration to give their businesses an edge. Enter WeWork. Their solutions are inherently flexible and built for all the ways people work today. WeWork has solutions for individuals and for companies no matter what the size,
本集节目部分由全球领先的灵活办公空间提供商WeWork赞助。工作世界已经改变了，对吧？无论是完全远程办公、在办公室办公，还是介于两者之间，人们都在寻找能够激发灵感、连接彼此，并有助于提高生产力和协作以赋予其业务竞争优势的空间。这就是WeWork登场的时候了。他们的解决方案本质上非常灵活，专为当今人们的所有工作方式而打造。无论规模大小，WeWork都能为个人和公司提供解决方案，
from co-working memberships to hundreds of work spaces around the world, and dedicated office space for teams of all sizes to collaborate. Their space is foster collaboration and connectivity. Bring teams together in person and work alongside some of the most innovative companies today. Get the flexibility your team needs with monthly memberships without the long-term commitments that can change just as easily as your needs do. WeWork makes it easy.
从共享办公会员资格到遍布全球的数百个办公空间，再到适合各种规模团队协作的专属办公空间。他们的空间促进了协作和连通性。将团队聚集在一起进行面对面交流，并与当今最具创新力的公司并肩工作。获取你团队所需的灵活性，通过包月会员资格免除那些可能随着你需求变化而变化的长期承诺。WeWork让这一切变得简单。
Get into a turnkey office with furniture, Wi-Fi, and other amenities ready to use on day one without all the upfront costs. Interested in finding out more? Visit WeWork.com slash SmartList. Hey SmartLifts fans, have you heard you can listen to episodes of this very show Add Free and one week early on Amazon Music with your prime membership? That's right, all your favorite smartlifts episodes can be heard Add Free anytime on Amazon Music, and you'll always be the first one to catch our new episodes so you can
入住即用，配备家具、Wi-Fi和其他开箱即用的便利设施，第一天即可投入使用，省去了所有前期成本。有兴趣了解更多吗？请访问WeWork.com/SmartLess。嘿，SmartLess的粉丝们，你们听说过吗？只要拥有Amazon Music的Prime会员身份，你就可以在节目播出前一周免广告收听这个节目的单集。没错，你所有最喜欢的SmartLess单集都可以随时在Amazon Music上免广告收听，而且你将永远是第一批收听我们新单集的人，这样你就可以
brag to your friends. But that's not all, you can listen to your other favorite shows, like, I don't know, Bad Dates and Just Jack and Will. Early and ad-free too. They also have favorites like The Daily Part and My Take and Up First. Amazon Music offers the most ad-free top podcast so we know they definitely have something for you.
向朋友们吹嘘了。但这还不是全部，你还可以提前免广告收听其他你喜欢的节目，比如，我不知道，比如《Bad Dates》和《Just Jack and Will》。他们还有像《The Daily》和《My Take》以及《Up First》这样的热门节目。Amazon Music提供最多免广告的顶级播客，所以我们知道这里面绝对有适合你的内容。
And it's already included in your prime membership. To listen now, all you need to do is go to Amazon.com slash smartless. That's Amazon.com slash smartless. That's Amazon.com slash smartless. Or download the Amazon Music app. It's just that easy. And now back to the show. How do you like that new thing now? Are, am I wrong?
而且它已经包含在你的Prime会员资格中了。要立即收听，你只需要访问Amazon.com/smartless。也就是Amazon.com/smartless。也就是Amazon.com/smartless。或者下载Amazon Music应用。就是这么简单。现在让我们回到节目中。你觉得现在这个新玩意儿怎么样？难道是我弄错了？
Or there are no more on Piers calling lines. It's now computer yet they put in a speaker of somebody like an audio somebody saying out or whatever, right? Isn't it? It's new. It's automated now, isn't it? I don't mean to be a
还是说现在没有人在边线上喊“出界”了？现在是电脑技术，它们安插了一个扬声器，播放某个人的声音，比如音频里的某个人在喊“出界”之类的话，对吧？难道不是吗？这是新技术的产物，现在已经是自动化了，对吧？我并不是想表现得
cynic, but I'd like to know how accurate it was, but you know, having said that, it is. Actually, if you knew that you had a chance to sort of double check a call, you know, I went to Wimbledon the first year I played there, and I'm playing a match, and I look over and the guy's sleeping,
愤世嫉俗，但我很想知道它的准确度有多高，不过话虽如此，确实如此。实际上，如果你知道你有机会去仔细核对一个判罚，你知道的，我第一次去温网打比赛的那一年，我正在打一场比赛，我转头一看，那个家伙竟然在睡觉，
you know, one of the lines, man. And I'm like, he's probably seeing the ball better now that he's asleep, because they can't see a damn thing. And so you... I always dreamed about being one of those guys. Did you? But big ones. Yeah, I watched you.
你知道的，就是其中一个司线员。当时我就想：他现在睡着了，可能反而能把球看得更清楚，因为他们根本什么都看不见。所以你……我一直梦想着能成为那些球童之一。是吗？但得是大的那种。对，我看着你。
I watched tennis and I watched you and I'd be like, I want to be the kid who runs across and catches you. Oh, the ballboy ball. That's, yeah, that's a cool. It's actually a tough gig to get, apparently. I ball-boyed for a handful of years at the US Open. So you get close to it. At Forest Hills?
我看网球，看着你，当时我就想：我想成为那个跑过去接住你的球的男孩。哦，球童。那是，对，那是个很酷的角色。据说这份差事其实挺难争取的。我在美网当过几年的球童。所以你能近距离接触它。在森林山网球俱乐部？
At Forest Hills? At Forest Hills. And by the way, the answer to your question, the electronic equipment, I would have been, you see, my hair might have been closer to your color, Jason. And I would have won more, but maybe I wouldn't have been on your amazing podcast. You know, you still would be. So I got to look at the bright side that, you know, your game was better than your
在森林山？在森林山。顺便说一句，回答你的问题，如果有了电子设备，我当时……你看，我的头发颜色可能更接近你的颜色，杰森。我会赢得更多比赛，但也许我也不会登上你这个精彩的播客了。你知道的，你还是会上的。所以我得看光明的一面，那就是，你知道的，你的球技比你的
efforts. I would have been more boring. No, your game was better than your average. I would have been more boring. No, your game was better than your average. Did you ever look back on some of those old freakouts that you had out for us over a call and that turned out you were right? Were you right like 100% of the time now that that's what I tell myself. Yeah. No, but it tells me it might not have been quite a hundred percent, but there was that
努力……我本会变得更无趣的。不，你的球技比你的平均水平要好。我本会变得更无趣的。不，你的球技比你的平均水平要好。你有没有回想起过去在场上因为一个最终证明你是对的判罚而大发雷霆的时刻？现在回想起来，你是不是100%的时候都是对的？这就是我对自己说的。对。不，但这告诉我，可能并非百分之百准确，但确实有那么一个
call. You know, the ball was in. You know, chalk flew up. I did that one. And 30 years later, we literally did it last year. I played the, or two years ago, because it was 81 that had happened. The guy that I was playing against came on ESPN and said, John was right. The ball did hit the line. Chalk did fly up.
判罚。你知道的，那球明明在界内。你知道的，白垩粉都飞起来了。我经历过那次。30年后，我们实际上在两年前又重演了一次——因为那是81年发生的事。当年和我对阵的那个家伙在ESPN上露面并说：“约翰是对的。球确实砸到了线。白垩粉确实飞起来了。”
And I just was like, yeah, it's 30 years before, but vindication, finally, not that I'm worse than Jack the Ripper. So, and Wimbledon, you can challenge a call because there's still people calling the lines, but the US open, it's automated, right? That's correct. It's going to be all automated within a few years. I think baseball is doing the same thing. Are they?
当时我的反应就是：“好吧，虽然迟了30年，但终于沉冤得雪了，并不是说我比开膛手杰克还要恶劣。”所以，在温网，你可以对判罚提出挑战，因为那里仍然有人在喊边线，但在美网，一切都是自动化的，对吧？没错。几年之内，所有比赛都会实现完全自动化。我想棒球也在做同样的事情。是吗？
Well, maybe they should, because if you play baseball, just think about this. And, you know, the umpire calls a ball that's clearly outside the plate. Why is that a strike? I don't give a damn who you are. It's the plate. Yeah, exactly. But meanwhile, they're like, well, that's the umpire. He's, you know, he's given the picture a little extra, you know, a couple extra inches. What why would be my question? Yeah, it should be without opinion or nuance.
嗯，也许他们应该这么做，因为如果你打棒球，想想这个。而且，你知道的，裁判判了一个明显在好球区外面的球。为什么那会是个好球？我才不管你是谁。那就是好球区。对，完全正确。但与此同时，他们的说辞是：“哦，那是裁判。他正在，你知道的，给投手多一点额外的好球带，多出那么几英寸。”为什么？这成了我的疑问。对，判罚应该是不带任何主观意见或细微差别的。
Right. But let me say this and this might be controversial. Uh-oh. I've felt, and I'm serious. I felt like with all the instant replay and shit, especially when you have VAR and soccer which, you know, every goal they look at. I feel like it's taken a little bit of, it's just, it's not opinions, just nuance.
对。但我要说的是，这可能会引发争议。哦哦。我一直觉得，我是认真的。我一直觉得，有了所有的即时回放和那些破玩意儿，尤其是当足球比赛中有VAR时，你知道的，每一个进球他们都要反复观看。我觉得这剥夺了一点……这已经不是主观意见了，这只是微小的差别。
And the human error should be part of kind of everything. I think so too. I liked it. It made a story when they get the wrong call. That's the wrong. Well, tell your other wrong side. If you're on the wrong side, I agree if you're on the wrong side.
人类犯错本该是各种体验的一部分。我也这么觉得。我挺喜欢这样的。当他们做出错误的判罚时，反而能制造一个故事。那是错误。好吧，说说你经历的其他错误判罚。如果你站在错误的一边……如果你在错误的一边，我同意。
I'm trying to get a part of the game. Why shouldn't. That stuff be taken out and what is left is just pure execution by the athletes. I think that what you're saying about the human element, there's some truth to that, but as an ex-athlete, if you know that the call could be corrected properly, I mean, and that could be the difference
我试图让这成为比赛的一部分。为什么不应该把那些争议抹去，而剩下的只是运动员纯粹的执行力呢？我认为你所说的人性化元素，确实有一定道理，但作为前运动员，如果你知道判罚可以被正确地纠正——我是说，那可能会成为
between winning and winbling and losing. I mean, that would be hard to argue if you're an athlete at any point to say that you should have that. I totally get that. And obviously, I'm not an athlete. And so I, I can see, yeah, the injustice of it. Just so Jason, in baseball, they would just get rid of the umpire then. No, the umpire would still be there to make a cause it plays on the plate.
赢得温网冠军与失利之间的天壤之别。我是说，如果你是一个运动员，无论在哪个阶段，要说你本不该拥有这种纠错机会，这都是很难反驳的。我完全理解这一点。显然，我不是运动员。所以，我，我能看到其中的不公。为了让杰森明白，在棒球比赛中，他们会直接取消裁判吗？不，裁判仍然会留在场上，对本垒板附近的击球做出判罚。
Um, I mean, I'm not. I there to make a cause it plays on the plate. I'm not potted. And to sweep the plate. And yeah, you know, you know, that's very important. Yeah, very important. John, let me ask you something about, and we've asked other folks that are incredible champions that are no longer playing their sport, where they scratch that old itch of competition and challenging yourself and seeing what you got, weekend and week out, was that something that was an easy adjustment for you? Is it a current adjustment for you or where do you sit with all that? Yeah, actually, it's a constant thing, you know, and I've tried to sort of taper off slowly.
我的意思是，我不是……留在场上对本垒板附近的击球做出判罚。我不是……并在本垒板上清扫尘土。而且，你知道的，你知道的，那非常重要。对，非常重要。约翰，让我问你关于……我们曾问过其他那些不再打球的杰出冠军，他们是如何填补那种对竞争、挑战自我以及周复一周检验自己真实水平的旧日渴望的？对你来说，这是一个轻松的适应过程吗？这至今仍然是一个需要适应的过程吗？你现在对此作何感想？是的，实际上，这是一个持续存在的过程，你知道的，我一直在试图慢慢减少这种冲动。
What happens if no one wanted me to play tennis anymore? You know, I've been asked this a lot. Do you love tennis? And my answer to it is, I don't know if I love it because I've never played it where I played it for nothing. I'm still asked, like, believe it or not, you know, and I hope no, that never gets to that point, by the way, that I have to play for nothing. But if I do, you'd have a better idea
如果没人再让我打网球了会怎么样？你知道的，这个问题我被问过很多次。你热爱网球吗？我的回答是，我不知道我是否热爱它，因为我从来没有在“什么都不为”的情况下打过网球。我至今仍然会被邀请去打比赛，信不信由你，你知道的，我希望……不，永远别走到那种地步，顺便说一句，我必须为什么都不为而打球。但如果我真的沦落到那一步，你就会有更深刻的体会了。
whether how much you still wanna be part of it. But I've learned over time that there's, you're always gonna be, I'll speak for myself, very competitive, but I'm not as competitive as I was when I was playing. It's not the end-all be-all. As much as I like to beat you that second 18 Augusta, when you came on and hit a shot in 80 or 81 or whatever it was, and I was flailing and hitting balls in the water, I'm
无论你还想不想成为其中的一部分。但随着时间的推移我明白，你总是会——我只代表我自己——非常有竞争力，但我已经没有当球员时那么好胜了。这并非生死攸关的事。尽管我很想在奥古斯塔的第二个第18洞击败你，当时你上场在80或81杆左右打出一记好球，而我却在笨手笨脚地把球打进水里，我当时
like, try to get a little perspective here, John. Life's pretty good. Will couldn't make it because his buddy passed away, you know, and saying, you know, all things considered, how lucky, you know, that type of thing. And, you know, again, I know you guys have kids. I got six. If I'm sitting there telling my kids, you know, I should have won the French.
就想，约翰，试着放平心态吧。生活其实挺美好的。威尔因为好友去世没能来，你知道的，他就说，从各方面来看，我们是多么幸运，诸如此类的话。而且，再次声明，我知道你们都有孩子。我有六个。如果我坐在那儿告诉我的孩子们，你知道的，我本来该赢得法网的。
I should have done this. Why didn't I do that? You know, and then I still want to beat their ass on the basketball or tennis court. I mean, I think that would be sort of like the wrong message to be sending to my kids or the kids at my academy. Yeah, are you kids in sports?
我本该做到这个的。我当时为什么没那样做呢？你知道的，然后我还想在篮球场或网球场上把他们打得落花流水。我的意思是，我觉得这给我的孩子或我网校的孩子们传递的会是一种错误的信息。对啦，你们的孩子搞体育吗？
It depends how loosely you define sports. They did play high school basketball and high school tennis and one of my boys played college for a year. But you need that like fire in the belly if you really wanted to do it in a serious way. And I don't know. I think I love my kids. And thankfully, Naka and Moira, they're doing well
这取决于你对体育的定义有多宽泛。他们确实打过高中篮球和高中网球，我的一个儿子还打过一年大学校队。但如果你真的想认真地在这条路上走下去，你需要那种内心的渴望。我不知道。我想我爱我的孩子。谢天谢地，娜卡（Naka）和莫伊拉（Moira），他们现在都过得很好，
all of them right now. But they had a little bit. And this is my fault, what you call affluenza. Yeah, sure. Maybe they're that hunger that maybe you need to succeed at, you know, a professional level. Sean's got that hunger,
他们所有人都是。但他们身上有点……这是我的错，也就是所谓的“富贵病”。对，当然。也许他们缺乏那种在职业层面上取得成功所需的饥饿感。肖恩有那种饥饿感，
that fire in the belly, but it's for a foot long, foot long stuff. But, you know, they, you're, but John, your kids, like everyone else on the planet, always is probably looking for something that they fit with and can excel in or at least put themselves in a situation to see what they've got. And it sounds like while it was pretty clear what you had with tennis, you know,
那种内心的渴望，不过那是针对一英尺长的食物。但是，你知道的，他们……但约翰，你的孩子们，就像地球上的其他人一样，可能总是在寻找一个能让他们融入并擅长的领域，或者至少为自己创造一个了解自己潜力的机会。听起来，虽然你在网球上展现出的天赋非常清晰，但，
the father clock or father time doesn't stop, sorry. And, you know, everybody ages out and everything. It sounds like you have found the other things that you can see. What have I got? You become like the best announcer ever in tennis and will probably be equally good in any other sport. Your philanthropy, your parenting, your music stuff. It sounds like you are, I don't want to put words in your mouth, but it sounds like you are sated, right? I mean, you're not hungry for arenas to see what you've got. No, no, I feel like I'm in,
岁月不饶人，时光老人是不会停下脚步的，抱歉。而且，你知道的，所有人都会变老，一切都会过去。听起来你已经找到了其他能让你看到自己的领域。我到底有什么本事？你成了网球界最伟大的解说员，而且在其他任何运动中大概也同样出色。你的慈善事业，你的育儿，你的音乐。听起来你——我不想替你做决定，但听起来你已经心满意足了，对吧？我的意思是，你不再渴望去各大竞技场证明自己了？不，不，我觉得自己正处于，
I've worked at this for 40 years, literally. And I feel like I found that sweet spot and been able to appreciate more the things that I enjoy doing and want to do them as often as possible. And to enjoy, you know, one of the reasons why I love commentary work still is I only were doing the majors. You know, I didn't want to go on tour and do it all the time. So I get to, you know, super pumped up for the eight weeks of the majors, do some stuff here and there, maybe 10 weeks. And I was still playing because, you know, there's never, never anything that will duplicate
我literally（简直）为之奋斗了40年。我觉得我找到了那个甜点时刻（最佳状态），并且能够更加感激那些我喜欢做的事情，并希望尽可能频繁地去做它们。而且去享受，你知道的，我依然热爱解说工作的原因之一是，我只解说大满贯赛事。你知道的，我不想去巡回赛上成天这么干。所以我可以，你知道的，对大满贯的那八周充满超级激情，偶尔在这里和那里做点别的，大概10周吧。我以前还在打比赛，因为，你知道的，永远没有什么东西能够复制
the speed on the center court at Wimbledon, but you know, still going out and competing, I played the seniors to, or they have it in golf, obviously it's harder in other sports, but I did that for 25 years. I made it close to 60. So I'm sitting there going, man, you're pretty, you know, you got to look at the bright side in this one.
温网中心球场的速度，但你知道的，依然走出去参加比赛，我打过常青组巡回赛，或者他们在高尔夫球里也有，显然在其他运动中这更难，但我坚持了25年。我一直打到快60岁。所以我坐在那儿想，伙计，你真的很……你知道的，你得看到这其中的光明面。
So whatever comes your way, if someone, at some point, it's like, who's that guy? You know, I didn't think I'd get the gig as a night writer of a show, never have I ever, where I'm like the psychologist for, you know, high school Indian American girl trying to figure out her way in her school. I didn't see that one coming. And part of the reason I'm gonna throw this in,
所以无论未来发生什么，如果有一天，有人会问：那家伙是谁？你知道的，我从没想过自己能接到一份工作，去给一部剧——《好想做一次》——担任旁白，我从来没想过自己会成为剧里那个亚裔高中女孩的心理医生，帮她摸索出在学校生存的道路。我完全没预料到会有这一出。部分原因——我想补充一点，
I was asked to be the commencement speaker at Stanford this year, which I was turned out I was the first athlete in 120 years to did it. And I was a Stanford dropout. So that was, you know, and the Stanford class presidents talked to me. One of the big reasons why we picked you because you were a narrator, I'll never have I ever.
今年我应邀去斯坦福大学做毕业典礼演讲，结果证明我是120年来第一个做这件事的运动员。而且我还曾是斯坦福的辍学生。所以那是，你知道的，斯坦福的级长跟我谈过。我们选择你的一个主要原因是因为你是《好想做一次》的旁白。
And I'm like, my God. You gotta be kidding me. So, you never know. So who would have thought? So thank you, Mindy Kaylee. Yeah, no, no, no. But that's, look, I understand that we never thought that we'd be doing this thing this podcast. And never before three years ago, and it was just like on a
当时我就想，我的天啊。你开什么玩笑。所以，你永远说不准。谁能想到呢？所以谢谢你，敏迪·卡灵（Mindy Kaling）。对，对，对。但那是……听着，我明白，我们从没想过我们会做这个播客。而且在三年前从没想过，这就像是一次
larke, and now this is like a big part of our lives, and it's fucking crazy. It's crazy. John, two things I want to know. First of all, right off the top of my head, where you stand currently on it. I don't think you're still endorsed, but I mean, you had some of the greatest surgery of Tekini track suits warmups of all time. And where you stand on the Sergio Tikinis, did you have any of those great beautiful zipups left?
随兴之举，而现在这成为了我们生活中的很大一部分，这他妈太疯狂了。太疯狂了。约翰，有两件事我想了解一下。首先，顺便问一下，你目前对它的态度是什么。我觉得你现在应该没有代言了，不过我的意思是，你曾拥有过史上最棒的一些Sergio Tacchini田径运动服和热身服。你对Sergio Tacchini现在怎么看？你还留着那些漂亮的大拉链运动服吗？
I mean, they're incredible. Yeah, Sergio Tikini, back in the day, feel a lesse with bass, you know the quality, made in Italy. Made it into some nice, a lesse, I got some nice lesse. And by the way, I'm the longest serving. I'm still believing in our Phil Knight, still has me under contract with Nike.
我的意思是，它们太不可思议了。对啊，Sergio Tacchini，当年还有Fila、Lesse、Bata，你知道那种品质，意大利制造。做成了一些漂亮的，Lesse，我有一些漂亮的Lesse。顺便说一下，我是合作时间最长的。我仍然坚信我们的菲尔·耐克（Phil Knight），耐克现在和我还有合同。
I've been signed with them since May of 1978. So I'm 45 years. Wow. When is the next Mac and Rotten issue coming out? It came out. I just did a little spot. It's on the internet. Check it out.
我和他们从1978年5月就开始签约了。所以已经45年了。哇。麦克与罗滕（Mac and Rotten）的下一期什么时候发？已经出了。我刚拍了个小短片。在网上呢。去看看吧。
Me and Travis Scott. Because he loves that my old sneaker was called the Mac attack. So it's being reintroduced. Go ahead, Will. John, you had used to have your first one was the Mac and Row all court, right? Was that the one with the Wimble then, you know, as the original sort of like this person who stands Smith, what he did with the D this and then I went to sort of like the three quarters, which was actually like a
我和特拉维斯·斯科特（Travis Scott）。因为他很喜欢我以前的那款名叫Mac Attack的运动鞋。所以它现在被重新推出了。说吧，威尔。约翰，你以前最开始穿的那款是麦肯罗全场鞋（MacEnroe All-Court），对吧？那是温网时期的那款吗？你知道的，最初的那种就像史密斯（Stan Smith）那样，他对底底做了一些处理，然后我换成了那种四分之三帮的，实际上那原本是用来打
racket ball, which is now everyone pretty much uses. And then the Mac attack. So it was nice that they reintroduced that and Travis Scott apparently takes a sneaker like that and does, you know, puts a little, if zone touch on it or does this something a little differently and unbelievably, you know, more people are asking me about that than almost anything else. So it's crazy. They want to do another one with me in Travis Scott.
壁球的，现在基本上所有人都在用它。然后就是Mac Attack。所以他们重新推出这款鞋真是太好了，而特拉维斯·斯科特显然拿走了这样一双鞋，并加入了，你知道的，融入了他自己的风格或者做了一些稍微不同的改动，不可思议的是，你知道的，现在向我打听这件事的人比其他任何事情都多。所以这太疯狂了。他们想和我还有特拉维斯·斯科特再合作一款。
I'm like, I don't know where you are. I think you do a golf shoe. You do a golf shoe. Yeah, I'm open for suggestions. Let's do the smart list. Can we do the smart list, Mack and Rogoff shoe? Can we do it? Let's do that.
我说，我不知道你在哪。我觉得你可以出一款高尔夫球鞋。你可以出一款高尔夫球鞋。对，我持开放态度，欢迎提议。我们来做“聪明人”播客鞋吧。我们能做一双“聪明人”麦肯罗高尔夫球鞋吗？我们能做吗？咱们做这个吧。
Let's do that. Come on, let's do that. What, before we let you go, what's the thing that people would be most surprised that you do? We know about tennis, we know about music, know about golf, is there a hobby that you just can't live without or a little pastime, even if it's just watching TV, or maybe even reading. Will likes to read about World War II. A lot of people don't know that.
咱们做这个吧。来吧，我们做这个。在让我们离开之前，有什么事是人们最意想不到你会去做的？我们知道你打网球，知道你搞音乐，知道你打高尔夫，有没有哪个是你没有它就活不下去的爱好，或者某个小消遣，哪怕只是看电视，或者甚至是读书？威尔喜欢读关于二战的书。很多人并不知道这一点。
A lot of people don't. I'm pretty much an open book, more or less. What you see is what you get. I do have a passion. I'm thankfully, I love music. It keeps me humble in a way, because I've obviously been around so many great rock guys and seen so many shows.
很多人都不知道。我基本上是一本摊开的书，大同小异。所见即所得。我确实有一个激情所在。谢天谢地，我热爱音乐。某种程度上它让我保持谦逊，因为我显然接触过那么多伟大的摇滚乐手，看过那么多演出。
And it's like, who you hell? My marriage or incredible thing. I was just saying, you're married, too. And so that's, you know, she sent to me way back when I said, because she was disillusioned. She had, you know, sold a couple million records, but it wasn't, you know, felt like she was treated fairly now as a woman and she was disillusioned. So I'm coming in and I'm like, hey,
然后就像是，你算老几？我的婚姻是一件不可思议的事。我刚才正要说，你也结婚了。所以，你知道的，她很久以前对我说过——因为她当时幻灭了。她曾，你知道的，卖出了几百万张唱片，但并没有，你知道的，觉得自己作为一个女性得到了公正的对待，她当时感到幻灭。所以我走过去，就像是，嘿，
why don't we have a band together? I'll join your band. I've got a lot of energy, and she goes, yeah, we should play mixed doubles at Wimbledon also. And I go, I go, you don't play tennis, and she goes exactly. So that was 28 or nine years ago. So it's kept me, my perspective, I still love it.
我们为什么不组个乐队呢？我加入你的乐队。我有很多精力。然后她说，对啊，我们干脆去温网打混双得了。然后我说，我说，你不会打网球啊。她说，没错。那是28或29年前的事了。所以它一直保持着我的心态，我还爱着它。
I try to be less, I guess one thing that would be different is that I try to be less competitive. Yeah, yeah. Actually. Yeah. You know, because you look at me and the way I played and obviously the people saw that I was pretty competitive. So there always, you know, if God forbid, I don't scream or fall over on the golf course,
我尽量少……我想有一点不同的是，我尽量让自己不那么好胜。对，对。实际上。对。你知道的，因为你看着我以及我的打球方式，显然人们看到我非常好胜。所以总是，你知道的，如果老天保佑，我在高尔夫球场上没有尖叫或者摔倒，
they're like upset at me now. You guys will say like, we're not going to invite you to Bel Air scream or fall over on the golf course. They're like upset at me now. You guys say like, we're not gonna invite you to be there unless you fall over at least once you scream and skip. And skip, Bronson. We only mention skip every fourth episode. Hey, do you know, John, I will say this as this is not a question, it's a compliment. Of all the times I met you over the last 20 years, you're so consistently yourself. And I think that, and it really shows.
他们现在反而会生我的气。你们会说，我们才不邀请你去贝莱尔呢，除非你在高尔夫球场上尖叫或摔倒。他们现在反倒生我的气了。你们会说，我们才不邀请你去那儿呢，除非你至少摔倒一次、尖叫并跳跃。还有跳跃，布朗森（Bronson）。我们每隔三期才会提到一次斯基普（Skip）。嘿，你知道吗，约翰，我要说的是——这不是一个问题，而是一个赞美。在过去20年里我所有见到你的时刻里，你都如此始终如一地做你自己。我认为，这真的很明显。
And like you said, what you see is what you get. That's true. You are very, you're an authentic guy. And you really are you, whether you're talking to the biggest rock star, or you're talking to the guy who's bringing you your car, you're the exact same dude. And I think it speaks a lot to your character. So, you know, it's that. Well, I've never seen such an sincere like you're not doing a thing.
就像你说的，所见即所得。确实如此。你是一个非常真实的人。你真的就是你自己，无论你是跟最大的摇滚巨星说话，还是跟那个把车开过来给你的人说话，你都完全是同一个德行。我觉得这很能说明你的品格。所以，你知道，就是这样。好吧，我从未见过如此真诚的人……就像你不是在装模作样。
It's true. Enjoy being you. I do. And I want to thank my wife, Patty, Smythe, for, because the greatest thing you can have in a relationship, it's been 29 years now. That's so. It's to let the person be the person you want to be. And she's allowed me to do that.
真的。享受做你自己吧。我会的。我要感谢我的妻子帕蒂·史密斯（Patty Smythe），因为在一段关系中你能拥有的最棒的事情——现在已经29年了。太棒了。就是让这个人成为你想成为的那个人。而她一直允许我这么做。
So love you, baby. Thank you. Thank you. I appreciate it. Hey, what band are you loving listening to right now? I'm more of like the Grunge guy. I'm looking for new stuff. We grunge.
所以，爱你，宝贝。谢谢你。谢谢你。我很感激。嘿，你现在最喜欢听哪个乐队的歌？我更偏向于垃圾摇滚（Grunge）那一挂。我在寻找新音乐。我们搞垃圾摇滚。
So you're into Pearl Jam and Sound Garden. No, I'm not going to go see the food fighters. Yeah, I know. I love stuff. So good. You know, I love Kingsley see the food fighters. Yeah, I know. I don't have stuff on. So good. You know, I love Kingsley on two. Yeah. But there doesn't seem to be like the new rock stars
所以你喜欢珍珠果酱（Pearl Jam）和声音花园（Sound Garden）。不，我不打算去看喷火战机乐队（Foo Fighters）。对，我知道。我喜欢那种音乐。太棒了。你知道，我喜欢金斯利……去看喷火战机乐队。对，我知道。我没有放那首歌。太棒了。你知道，我喜欢金斯利播放的两首。对。但似乎没有那种新的摇滚明星了，
are the rap guys. Yeah, and or it's all electric or something. Yeah. Rock is sort of a little like tennis, you know. I mean, we got to get our act together. Yeah, yeah. All right. Yeah.
现在的都是说唱歌手。对，要么全都是电子乐之类的。对，摇滚乐有点像网球，你知道的。我的意思是，我们得振作起来。对，对。好吧。对。
Well, John, thank you for spending some time with us, buddy. Please come back to Los Angeles soon so we can you for spending some time with us, buddy. Please come back to Los Angeles soon so we can go play some golf. Love to, man. Thanks for having me. Appreciate it. And awesome. Thank you, buddy.
好了，约翰，谢谢你花时间陪我们，老兄。请快点再来洛杉矶，这样我们就能……谢谢你花时间陪我们，老兄。请快点再来洛杉矶，这样我们就能去打高尔夫球了。我很乐意，伙计。谢谢你们邀请我。我很感激。太棒了。谢谢你，伙计。
Thank you very much. All right. Can't wait to see you again. All right, John. Thanks, John. Bye, buddy. All right, man. Bye.
非常感谢。好的。迫不及待想再次见到你。好的，约翰。谢谢，约翰。再见，伙计。好的，伙计。再见。
Yeah, I really mean that about him. He is, he is, you know, I find myself saying this to my daughters as often as they'll bear me saying it. That's daddy's. Oh, sorry. Is there's just, there's just one of all of us. You know, so why would you waste any time trying to be someone else? I mean, I'm inviting that from someone else, famously said that I'm sure, but he so clearly himself,
是的，关于他，我是真心这么觉得的。他真的是，他真的是——只要我的女儿们还能听得进去，我就会经常对她们说这句话。那就是爸爸的……哦，抱歉。世界上所有的我们当中，就只有，就只有一个。你知道的，所以你为什么要把时间浪费在试图成为别人身上呢？我的意思是，我很赞同某位名人的说法，虽然具体是谁我记不清了，但他如此清晰地做自己，
he's unique, he's singular, and he enjoys that, makes no apologies for it, and it is encouraging. It's infectious. He's the same when you, if you're having something to eat with him, or we remember we played with him at RIV, we played in the pro-AM. If he's teeing off in front of 100 people, if he's walking to the thing, if you're grabbing, he's the same. He's like, he's talking the same way in the supermarket and the checkout line.
他是独一无二的，他是无可替代的，而且他很享受这一点，从不为此道歉，这很鼓舞人心。富有感染力。当你和他一起吃东西时，他是那个样子；还记得我们在里维埃拉（RIV）和他一起打球吗，我们参加了职业业余配对赛。如果他在100人面前开球，如果他走向某个地方，如果你在抓……他都是一样的。他在超市结账排队时说话的语气也是一样的。
He's just him and when he's in the booth too, right? When you listen to him on the broadcast, I wanted to tell him, I wanted to tell him I played tennis when I was a kid a lot. I took tennis lessons. Oh, he would love to hear that. Jesus. Are you back? You're snacking.
他就是他自己，当他在解说间里时也是如此，对吧？当你在广播里听他解说时，我想告诉他，我想告诉他我小时候经常打网球。我上过网球课。哦，他听到这个肯定会很高兴。天哪。你回来了？你在吃零食。
I love when you save. I love when you save some of your best comments for after the guest is going. What else would you have put into bed with? Um. Um. Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey the bike, like side saddle, and he would ride his bike all the way across town. And then on the way home, he crashed, and I blacked out, and I got a super fat lip, and the ambulance had a came.
我喜欢你把一些最精彩的评论留在嘉宾离开之后才说。你刚才还想插话说什么？呃。呃。嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿骑着自行车，侧着身子，他骑着自行车一路穿过整个小镇。然后在回家的路上，他摔车了，我当时失去了知觉，我的嘴唇肿得老高，救护车都来了。
And I was sitting on my neighbor's porch. And the craziest thing was the sentence, that the ambulance had a came. And the ambulance had a come. I just came up by the next step, when you're here. I mean, you really stood in there with the silver, you know, hair. Well, say at the pickup truck nearly, it sounds like the lyrics for Stone Me by Van Morrison. I thought he was just trying to back into a buy here, but no, no, no, no, no, no. No, I don't.
当时我正坐在邻居的门廊上。最疯狂的事就是那个句子，“救护车都来了（have a came）”。应该是“救护车来了（have a come）”。我刚才就想接下一句，当你在这里的时候。我的意思是，你真的站在那里顶着一头银发……好吧，说得好像范·莫里森（Van Morrison）的歌词《Stone Me》一样。我以为他刚才只是想把车倒进这里买点东西，但并没有，并没有，并没有……不，我才不呢。
Sean, what are you eating? Tell us what you're eating. I just put a grape in my mouth. Okay. A grape. Is it green? Hey, guys, let me ask you this. Okay. A grape. Is it green or red? Hey guys, let me ask you this. Do you think that...
肖恩，你在吃什么？告诉我们你在吃什么。我刚把一颗葡萄放进嘴里。好的。一颗葡萄。它是绿的吗？嘿，伙计们，让我问你们这个。好吧。一颗葡萄。它是绿的还是红的？嘿，伙计们，让我问你们这个。你们觉得……
Oh, it's red. Do you think that I want to know where you guys stand on? Because it happened that we kind of let it go. Where you guys land on Father Clock? Because... Father Clock. That was a low point for me. That was real.
哦，它是红的。你们觉得——我想知道你们对这件事的立场是什么？因为刚才我们差点把这事给跳过去了。你们对“时光老人（Father Clock）”持什么态度？因为……时光老人。那对我来说是一个低谷。那是真实的。
You know, the brain just doesn't fire like you used to. I don't forget. That was a low point for me. That was real. You know, the brain just doesn't fire like you used to. I don't forget. Father clock is... I'm gonna hold this in my high school band. We're gonna make smartness father clock, step sweatshirts. Yeah.
你知道，大脑运转的速度已经不如从前了。我没忘。那对我来说是一个低谷。那是真实的。你知道，大脑运转的速度已经不如从前了。我没忘。时光老人是……我要把这个印在我高中的乐队队服上。我们要制作“聪明人-时光老人”限定款运动衫。对。
And then father clock, you know, when you watch the father clock, you just watch time go. Bye! Very nice. You know when you watch the father clock, you just watch time go. Bye! Very nice. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
然后时光老人，你知道的，当你看着时光老人时，你就会看着时间流逝。拜拜！非常棒。你知道的，当你看着时光老人时，你就会看着时间流逝。拜拜！非常棒。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbaco, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Umjurf. SmartLess. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now early on Amazon Music, or early and add free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondry app. Okay, so if you had a time machine, how far in time would you need to go back to be a
聪明。SmartLess播客由Bennett Barbaco、Michael Grant Terry和Rob Amjerf百分之百有机手工制作。SmartLess。我们的下一期节目将在的一周后发布，你可以在任何收听播客的地方收听，或者现在就在亚马逊音乐（Amazon Music）上抢先收听，也可以通过在苹果播客（Apple Podcasts）或Wondry App上订阅Wondry Plus，抢先收听无广告版。好了，如果你有一台时间机器，你需要回到过去多久，才能成为那个时代最具统治力的篮球运动员？我得回到鲍勃·库西（Bob Cousy）打球的时候。
dominant basketball player of that era? I need to go to when Bob Coosie was playing. Back in the plumber days. 27 year old Shay would give Bob Coosie the business. He's not guarding me. Hi, I'm Jason Gitzapsion. And I'm Shay Serrano and we are back. We have a new podcast from Wondering.
回到管道工满地走的年代。27岁的谢伊能把鲍勃·库西打得落花流水。他可防不住我。嗨，我是杰森·康塞普西翁（Jason Concepcion）。我是谢伊·塞拉诺（Shea Serrano），我们回来啦。我们带来了Wondry的全新播客。
It's called Six Trophies. Woo! And it's the best. Each week Shay and I are combing through all of the NBA storylines finding the best, most interesting, most compelling ones and then handing out six pop culture themed trophies for six basketball related activities. Trofies like the Dominic Toretto, I live my life a quarter mile in a time trophy, which is given to someone who made a short-term decision with no
它叫《六座奖杯》（Six Trophies）。呜呼！它是最棒的。每周我和谢伊都会梳理所有的NBA故事线，找出最棒、最有趣、最引人入胜的故事，然后为六项与篮球相关的活动颁发六座流行文化主题奖杯。像“多米尼克·托雷托（Dominic Toretto）：我的人生以四分之一英里为单位”奖杯，颁发给那些为了眼前利益而完全不顾未来后果的人。
regard for future cons quets. Or the Christopher Nolan Tennett trophy, which is given to someone who did something that we didn't understand. Catalina Wine Mixer trophy. The Lauren Hilly might win some, but you just lost one trophy. Follow six trophies on the Wondery app or wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen to six trophies and free right now by joining Wondery Plus. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
或者是“克里斯托弗·诺兰的《信条》（Tenet）”奖杯，颁发给那些做了我们完全无法理解的事情的人。加泰罗尼亚葡萄酒混酿奖杯。劳伦·希利（Lauren Hilly）可能会赢得一些奖杯，但你刚刚弄丢了一座奖杯。在Wondry App或你获取播客的任何地方关注《六座奖杯》。你现在就可以通过加入Wondry Plus免费收听《六座奖杯》。本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。